the democrats on the january 6 committee
have subpoenaed many of trump's allies
notably steve bannon who is refusing to
comply with the subpoena which means the
democrats are going to hold him in
contempt and now you can see all across
twitter people are saying send in the
marshals they are gleefully cheering for
the arrest of a political rival who they
accuse of being involved in the
insurrection and it's all based on lies
it's all based on lies so we know that
steve bannon said that he was there
helping organize a rally
the leftist media then took that and
tried to make it seem like he said he
organized the active riot at the capitol
that is the sentiment require that
that's the the fake news that riles
people up who then say arrest him and
arrest him now and it's it's absolutely
getting crazy
we got other stories and fake news my
friends we've got cnn and joe rogan joe
rogan grilling sanjay gupta getting him
to say yes you're right cnn should not
have said ivermectin was horsty wermer
or that you were taking it but then
sanjay gupta goes on aaron burnett's
show who lied about it and don lemon's
show who lied about it and they doubled
down and sanjay gupta does not correct
them because they are fake news
but outside of that i think it's all
part of the bigger a bigger story in
that economy is collapsing we're on the
verge of some kind of civil war
we're actively seeing now people trying
to arrest each you know the political
rivals which is has been the case i
guess for several years we've just
resisted the actual action of doing so
but now it's looking like it's getting
to that point and we have a this is
crazy a jail warden in dc being held in
contempt
over violating the civil rights of one
of the january 6th defendants so maybe
that's some some some good news in the
end that some judges are actually going
to be like yo people have civil rights
but i think in the long run it's feeling
like falling apart well joining us to
talk all about this is will chamberlain
of human events
yes i'm a lawyer co-publisher of human
events senior counsel to the internet
accountability project which fights big
tech abuse um and always happy to be
here with you guys
well welcome hi my name is luke radowsky
and i really do believe that independent
media could only survive with members
area and that's why the shirt i'm
wearing right now is only one that you
could get exclusively by being a part of
lukeuncensored.com there's no profit to
us and you could wear our unofficial
uniform of our not secret society and uh
instagram is telling people not to
follow me we're going to be talking
about that later but uh yeah wow it's
crazy out there yeah
i unfollowed luke to see what would
happen then followed him and it's like
are you sure you want to follow this guy
he's fake news
our fact checker said so
it's it's mind-boggling uh i got a lot
to say about this like i feel like i
want to know this just in case i ever
everyone yeah is it contagious can we
catch the fake news from i mean you guys
you guys just followed me so you guys
are probably on the second list of the
main list so uh be warned i mean you
guys are there too so uh welcome to the
club i've been following you since
before you were fake news so i wonder if
they'll have me on some sort of list now
uh yeah i think uh a long time ago i
guess we're listing ourselves by putting
ourselves on social media interesting
world we live in hey will i'm glad
you're here jordan congratulations you
guys first time i've seen you guys since
uh you tied the knot
yes indeed the studio bro yeah now it's
good to be back a married man and a
baby on the way yes indeed we made a
public announcement about that
yeah so so what can bad life like
uh
it's nice i guess i i'm enjoying it very
much uh
is it that different from pre-married
life
not not out of the circumstances i guess
i don't know
you know very well spoke
awesome thanks man i'm also here pushing
buttons hopefully better tonight i'm
finally getting into the swing of things
i always find that getting a new routine
when you start a new like method of
doing things is key so bear with me
thanks guys before we get started my
friends head over to teamcast.com become
a member we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up after the show as per
usual it usually goes up around 11 or so
p.m and uh with your support we're
funding tons of awesome journalism we've
got new shows on the way we have the
green room show which is going to be a
member exclusive show of our green room
with our guests and that'll be every
friday so now we're going to have tim
castero stuff monday through friday with
the green room show we also have the new
show tales from the inverted world and
yes we are hosting an event live in
person with performances by ryan long
and danny polish chuck so you know ryan
and danny from all the skits they do
they'll be doing a stand-up routine it's
going to be in the harpers ferry area
and it's uh sold out like instantly so i
apologize to those who couldn't get
tickets but um
we'll have more information on the event
coming up it's going to be on october
23rd so about a week from now in harpers
ferry stay tuned there may still be an
opportunity for people to come if they
weren't able to get a ticket we will get
that all sorted uh that being said don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's talk about the news
let's talk about the absolute chaos that
is affecting this country and man the
spark of civil war never seemed closer
we got this from the bbc now i i chose
the bbc on purpose because it's not an
american news outlet so i was really
interested in how they would frame it
especially consider kind of left
establishment
they write steve bannon congress plots
criminal charge for former trump aide
mr bannon has been summoned to testify
before the congressional panel
investigating the riot on thursday he
did not appear prompting the head of the
committee to schedule a tuesday vote to
hold him in critical criminal contempt
if convicted mr bannon faces a fine up
to one year in prison democrats say he
is trying to delay the probe mr bannon a
former right-wing media executive who
became mr trump's chief strategist was
fired from the white house yeah yeah we
get it he was asked to testify regarding
his communication with mr trump a week
before the incident as well as his
involvement in discussing plans to
overturn the election results that saw
joe budden in the white house
i don't i don't know if that's fair
framing he's ought to overturn the
election results he certainly thinks
there's widespread fraud but what
they're doing is there was this thing he
said where he was like you know i was
there and i was talking with trump right
before the rally and like helped
organize it or something and they're
trying to take that and reframe it as
though he said he organized the riot
which he didn't now my bigger my the the
bigger thing here to me
that's scary
establishment democrats and for all
intents and purposes republicans but
they're actually democrats
are now actually going after people
they're going after private citizens to
force them to testify in their in their
crackpot probe this if they actually
come and arrest abandon over this
it's it's like we're dangerously close
in my opinion to a spark of some kind of
civil war um i i wouldn't be quite so
pessimistic in the short term because i
think ultimately the the amount of time
it will take them to even get to the
point right like
congress doesn't have the ability to
charge somebody with contempt or
prosecutor right they're they're relying
on referring it to the us attorney of dc
and then that actually has to go through
normal criminal process
um bannon's not just making a claim that
basically he's not he's making a claim
like i read the lawyer the letter he
sent to his lawyer or his lawyer sent to
the congress
and it he's they're claiming look the
you know the president's claimed his
executive privilege
and
i'm as an aide to him or somebody who
you know was talking to them i'm bound
by that i'll be happily to produce the
documents if you come to an agreement
with the trump you know the trump people
or if you get a court order
saying so
um under those circumstances i don't
know if they're going to be able to
prove criminal contempt it'll take a
long time to get proven
but i think
the really big problem here is you know
you notice what they're talking about
what is the january 6 commission about
is it designed to help with any
legislative purpose no no it's it that
and that's the bigger issue right yeah
i'm not saying that we're at the point
where you know all of a sudden we're
going to see another you know cnn
showing up at six in the morning to
bannon's house or anything like that but
we're we're we're moving from we had in
the trump era lock her up you know
arrest hillary clinton and a lot of
people being like yeah she should be
arrested i mean she should be locked up
for the email scandal at the very least
let alone
lots of other things that went down with
with uh you know the clinton foundation
and serious things that should be
investigated
and now we're moving towards
people are actively cheering and
screaming on both sides for the arrest
of the other side i can't imagine
regardless of who's right or wrong if
this is going to lead to somewhere
good no it's it's not and the fact that
we're even doing committees like this
like again congress is the reason they
have subpoena power they're not they're
not a court they're not and they also
don't have law enforcement power right
that's in the executive branch they have
legislative power so the goal of any
committee has to have some legislative
purpose they can you know it makes sense
they can subpoena something the
executive branch is doing because they
kind of oversee it they authorize the
funding for it but here it's like
they're doing an investigation of
private criminal behavior
right or what they think pri
objectionable private behavior well
that's that's a star chamber like
they're they don't have to go get a
warrant when they go issue these
subpoenas
um and so there has to be some
limitation on what they can subpoena
based on and they're and apparently
they've just decided no we we can just
subpoena people to embarrass our
political opponents and that's efficient
but this this is not nothing new i mean
they've been doing it to lower level
people and i think it's only escalating
to where it's now and i wouldn't be
surprised if even if it does take a long
time that they're still going to try to
go after abandoned criminally because
they go after people politically all the
time you look at the activities of the
fbi they are extremely political they
choose and select who they go after oh
jeffrey epstein 30 years doesn't matter
oh someone lied to congress
we have to get a swat team in front of
their house with cnn right in the
morning
as fast as we can as long as the name's
not james clapper exactly
exactly or dr fauci uh our lord and
savior dr fauci who's who's always right
never wrong
that was really one of my favorite
moments
when rand paul was like
you conducted gain of function research
gain of function research is defined as
modifying a virus to increase in you
know infectivity and then fouch is like
we didn't do gain of function research
we just modified a virus for increased
infectivity he went full
i am being deposed you know fauci who's
normally like open in his language and
very it is not a door yeah it is a large
wooden object with a latch that when you
turn a metal object releases it allowing
that that that wooden plank to be moved
yeah and it's just just a coincidence
that it's almost the same genetic
sequence that we were asking for grant
funding with the exact cleavage site
with the exact sickness that's going
around the world right now it's just you
know a coincidence uh not here to
question anything uh you know youtube
overlords please we love you you see
that woman who was skydiving
yes
there's a woman and she's skydiving and
the instructor who they're flying in
tandem his helmet said arrest fauci
infowars.com
and then she posted like i trusted this
man with my life and it wasn't until
after we saw the photo we realized what
the sticker said and she was like
shocked and i'm like what did you think
was going to happen that like this
flight instructor was like i'm going
down with her to like get her or
something they're attached together he's
got a sticker on us for it that's how
insane it is though you know
i think
there there's a one of the phenomena one
of the circumstances in the culture war
conservatives don't care interacting
with the left or i shouldn't even say
conservatives but like whatever the
freedom side is
doesn't mind going to a store owned by a
bunch of people with biden flags
there's a biden flags all over and they
sell cupcakes i look i want a cupcake i
don't care that much the other way
around though the throw brick through
your window this woman's freaking out
like i can't even go skydiving so look
donald trump didn't do
nearly enough with the presidential
powers the democrats as soon as they get
power
it's the equivalent of throwing a brick
through the window of the right yeah
there's a lot of republicans i remember
remember the national emergency debate
about whether the president should
declare a national emergency to try and
build the wall
and how much like establishing
republicans were like well this will set
a really bad precedent that democrats
could exploit and it's like you say that
and then when democrats say power they
all complain about look at all the
unprecedented things that democrats are
doing it's like if they do unprecedented
things maybe you shouldn't really care
that much about what precedence you set
because they don't the democrats don't
care but but will they're they're paid
you know a lot of money just to be you
know the second level democrats you
didn't know about this they're paid just
to be the cushion for you know the
globalist agenda that's just pushing
through that is such a good analogy who
came up with that one it wasn't me
originally uh but it might have been it
might have been kirk schlichter i don't
know
the republicans the washington generals
to the democrats harlem global some have
been yarvin uh back in the day i don't
know but like that's that's actually i
think yeah it's a very good description
like what is their purpose and so people
are like how come tim pool is always
ragging on democrats i'm like because
mitch mcconnell is sitting on his hands
that's about it yeah i mean like there's
not much to complain about other than
he's ineffective and well i'll tell you
this how much money did he make over his
career in the senate he's tens of
millions of dollars man screw all of
these corrupt
yeah i was almost going to swear but i
won't do it it's all the same it's all
the same they make say they somehow they
get a salary of you know 170 to 200k
they become worth 30 40 million dollars
nancy pelosi maxine waters buying a
mansion it's all the same there's
there's people on tick tock literally
making their careers off of stock picks
that nancy pelosi makes uh
the level of of seriously this is not
funny this is real nancy the amount of
money
the amount of money that she made is
absolutely insane but but what's
happening to bannon i believe as a part
of a slippery slope because we saw what
happened politically when people on the
left when they were protesting for left
issues were arrested they raised money
for them they got them out they hired
prose they they elected prosecutors
george soros dumped a huge amount of
money into local politics and they were
able to rig the game where their people
don't go to jail their people don't get
prosecuted but if you sneeze in the
wrong direction if you're a part of the
opposite party you're going to see a
heavy hammer come down on you
and with on average americans committing
three felonies a day when we have the
politization of our justice system we're
slowly evolving into the destruction of
it and i think this is the start
i think it started a long time ago but i
think this is the beginning of it and
it's i think it's only going to swell
and be made worse moving forward i see
someone in the chat said tim run for
senate and you know i was thinking about
it just now and i'm like if i did and i
won
i would get really really rich you know
because you you as a member of the
senate you'll make on average i think
two to three million dollars a year on
your 174 000 salary so it sounds sounds
pretty good you know run for senate
somehow become a millionaire because
it's just magic it's just you know just
all of a sudden money just appears and
yeah no one knows where it comes from
well i mean you know it comes from
hunter biden style deals you just you
just need to have children and then you
can have them go earn
you could get a you could probably get a
cushy job at pfizer afterwards or google
or you know you'll get some donations
from a lot of these multinational
corporations and industrial complexes i
mean your life is set and you get a
congressional salary for the rest of
your life do you really though i heard
that was a myth i don't i've heard that
was true someone will fact-check us very
soon here in the comment section which
i'm paying attention to i don't know but
uh
i i just
getting back to this i i want democrat
republicans next time in their power
which they probably will be and you know
we might have a desantis or somebody as
like a president yeah but like look
unless republicans win primaries
and that means getting america first or
populist candidates to actually win
you're gonna end up with kevin mccarthy
mcconnell graham and they're gonna be
like i'm gonna fight extra hard and then
the camera turns off and they high five
joe biden
the congress i don't know how to fix the
congress problem but i think you know
the executive branch is fixable in a
world where
a republican executive branch was
particularly ruthless in a way that made
democrats realize maybe we need to
change the rules but trump you mean not
trump trump trump is not the answer on
that front i mean
people trump was not ruthless enough
well i mean he was just like a novice
pilot in a 747 cockpit like he didn't he
got he didn't know what buttons to press
and like early on he pressed some
buttons really aggressively with like
the travel ban and a few other things
like that and got zapped and so then he
just kind of was like i'm just gonna put
the thing on autopilot like i'm when it
comes to exercising his executive
authority to try and like screw the
other side he's just like no i'm not
doing that and it's like he could have
pardoned a lot of people he could have
done so much with his power and it's
like that's why one of the reasons i'm
like i want a lawyer next time because
this isn't you know people are like man
we need a deal maker it's like no no
we're not making deals anymore there's
no deals to be made this isn't
bipartisan world this is use the legal
authority that you have available to you
to to cement your power and make the
other side's lives miserable isn't
desantis a lawyer yes okay that's our
harvard law degree let's talk about this
other story so uh will brought this up
to us before the show i missed this one
judge holds washington dc jail officials
in contempt in a january six riot case
basically they say uh that judge royce
lamberth summoned the jail officials as
part of the criminal case into
christopher warrell a member of the
proud boys who had been charged in the
january 6 attack at the capitol he'd
been accused of attacking police
officers with pepper spray gel and
prosecutors have alleged he traveled to
washington and coordinated with proud
boys
it's clear to me the civil rights of the
defendant were violated by the d.c
department of corrections lambert said i
don't know if it's because he's a
january 6th defender or not
the judge ordered quincy booth the
director of the city's department of
corrections and wanda patton the warden
of dc jail to be held in contempt of
court while he did not impose any
sanctions or penalties the judge said he
was referring the matter to the justice
department to investigate whether the
civil rights of the inmates in the jail
are being violated this is big so this
is over what was it he had he had a
surgery he needed or something he had a
broken wrist that he got in may mr
rorell who's also did he get the did he
get the break in jail yes he got the
break while in custody um and
uh apparently and
it still apparently has not yet gotten
the necessary surgery
um to do it you know this is a very very
basic thing we expect from our jails
um are they torturing these guys man
i mean the the the only you know the
best explanation the most charitable one
is just pure incompetence right like the
dc jail is just this bad for everybody
which is not exactly you know
heartwarming right either way you're
either intentionally making like these
people's lives miserable or yeah i know
the the dc defendants or the january 6
defense are kind of in their own
separate facility right now as my
understanding they were kept segregated
from the rest of the general population
and maybe that facility has just owned
huge problems
well if you remember last year when this
story was developing i was even telling
people um
sorry this year
earlier this year at around february i
was i was you know bringing up this
conversation where there was already
reports of torture of people being put
in solitary confinement of people being
beat back then so to hear that some of
these people are still in solitary
confinement that they're being held in
their own unit i mean this definitely
seems overboard i mean solitary
confinement for
walking into a building i mean some of
the people did commit some crimes but
but even then when you compare it to
you know some of the crimes happening in
major urban areas now i mean there's
there's there's uh not much to compare
here or just i mean even the treatment
of the of the uh you know the rioters
the antifa rioters
um over the course of the past few years
i mean there was actually one case um
judge trevor mcfadden you know he was
giving a sense and somebody who had plea
pled to misdemeanor and i think the you
know the the you know the government was
asking for three months in jail or
something like that and he gave them
like three months probation or in like
no jail time at all and basically said
like i don't think you guys are serious
you guys have not treated these the same
way as the other the defendants like
there is criminal activity here so
there's going to be a punishment you
pled to a misdemeanor that's a crime but
like you guys are you're wildly
overblowing this with asking for you
know serious car you know incarceration
we got to be real on part of it though
is that the left
has experience yeah and not just with
their tactics while they insurrect but
also also the legal apparatus so when uh
on on january 7 uh january it was
january of 2017
um 21st i think it was trump's
inauguration i was there uh luke you
were there yep we were running through
the streets and it's really funny what
happened was we were running and there
was this moment where luke and i made
two different choices
a row of police were forming and luke
just ran for it and i got pepper sprayed
very heavily for it because they were
spraying the pepper spray and i was like
i'm seeing the circle i'm like it's
either now or never i get out and i
decided to go into the stairwell of a
building unfortunately that's the
decision every other antifa made and the
cops immediately surrounded the whole
group
so this whole group of people which was
several hundred people ultimately after
like an hour i got released they said i
would have been arrested three times a
lot of people they don't know what
arrest means i wasn't pr i wasn't
processed or charged i was arrested but
eventually a supervisor came out showed
him my my press pass he pulled me and
some other journalists up but all of
those people were charged and they were
charged with conspiracy because they
couldn't prove
any one person was the person who was
setting things on fire who that torched
the limousine or through bricks through
windows and so they said charge them all
with conspiracy which which doesn't fly
the state has to prove you as a person
did something wrong and they can't prove
simply by wearing a hoodie
this is the tactic and it's why they do
it yeah regardless regardless
when it came to january 6 even if people
were wearing masks otherwise they went
above and beyond to torture these people
in prison these antifa people spent it
was overnight in jail the next day they
walked out to thunderous applause of
people outside these are people who were
running through the streets setting
fires beating like like smashing windows
destroying property they torched a limo
that belonged to some immigrant who had
a small business
these people get a slap on the wrist and
a lot of their charges were dropped too
i remember hearing a lot about their
charges the mainstream media was
actually talking about it how this was a
travesty of injustice how this was
political
prosecution and then i remember a lot of
people who were part of it got off but
you compare that to the story of thomas
caldwell he's a 66 year old navy and fbi
veteran and according to him he was
never inside of the capitol he never was
a part of oath keepers he never
committed any acts of violence against
the state that they but the state
charged him as the old keeper leader
saying that he led the charge organized
everything and put him in solitary
confinement for 49 days he was just able
to go out
of solitary confinement he's speaking
out against this story thomas caldwell
he is raising money because the legal
fees he says is uh is is exacerbating
him and destroying his livelihood and
he's uh he's saying that his farm is
going to be taken away soon so he's
still facing some legal court
proceedings but hearing stories of this
66 year old guy who again is an fbi
veteran is a is an old uh navy military
member to hear this kind of happened to
me definitely
shows me a totally different picture
than what happened during the trump
inauguration and look at that woman who
they the feds raided her house in alaska
wrong person wrong person because
someone uh on the airlines they got in
she got an argument over a mask um on
one of the airlines and they snitched
and they called the fbi and um
fbi followed up on the story
uh very digital vigilantly or digitally
yeah i mean diligently
we get to a point with these
conversations where i'm just like
can we just pull work like words out of
a hat to make headlines like if the
subject is the right gets censored the
libertarian the freedom the anti-war
types are the ones who get censored and
the establishment shills and the
democrats don't and the law enforcement
is heavily weighted against people who
are in support of freedom in opposition
to the establishment and antifa gets a
free pass and the proud boy's rotten
prison why why it's almost like do we
even need npr to tell us this is
happening we could just be like hey
here's the news guys
the january 6th defendants are being
tortured antivo's being let go moving on
i don't i don't need a source for that
because it just happens all the time
right
i mean you know our one i think as you
mentioned our side is very bad at crime
in no way that the left is not the left
is just much better at crime yeah they
are they you know i'm reminded of you
know charles barkley talking about jesse
smallett and being like america don't
commit crimes with checks well i want to
be like america don't don't enter the
capitol without a mask on
you know you're just
you're you're done that way but also
clearly there's just this enormous
double standard in the way they're
treated i'm reminded of like a gambin
and the state of exception the
sovereignness he who decides in the
exception and it's like we have this
world where
you know this is like the idea that we
have equal justice between different
political sides is the total fiction um
that what we're seeing is just is a
total joke and
even if republicans take back the house
they're not going to do anything they
won't impeach by they should they won't
he should be impeached i mean he he
could have been impeached the moment he
did that thing with the eviction
moratorium where he said i don't think
this is constitutional but i'm going to
do it anyway and the supreme court said
you can't do it and he goes yeah i'll do
it again
yeah and then it's like i know it's
probably going to be found
unconstitutional i just don't really
care and it'll it'll it'll last a couple
of months for it to go through the court
system and that's time that they won't
be evicted so that's fine like that's
impeachable you have a duty to take care
that the laws are faithfully executed so
if you knowingly violate the
constitution exhausting man it's
impeachable it's just but it's you know
they're
like they're so feckless and comparison
the democrats were already talking about
just putting republican political
operatives in jail people gotta get
active in the primaries and the state
level
that's that's everything but i saw that
kevin mccarthy has like record
fundraising you know he's like 60
million or something in the first nine
months of the year and i'm just like why
like he's so uh they don't they're just
they're they're they're on the same team
as the democrats to show exactly this is
why when you brought up clapper i
thought that james clapper sitting in
front of congress testifying saying we
did not wittingly spy on the american
people blatant lie
and then they let him go they still
charged him with any kind of perjury or
anything it's beyond general hayden
who's a part of newsguard literally said
the same thing former cia uh and nsa had
said no we're not spying on anyone
it's beyond politics it's like the
administrative state is protecting their
own yeah
maybe biden's part of that maybe of
course he's part of that of course he is
it's that's it's a big club and you
ain't in it i don't think you can use
politics to to
defend against that i mean you you know
that's ultimately
there is a world where you can but the
administrative state is subordinate to
the white house and the white house a
white house that knew what they were
doing and was really like aggressive
with their use of power could really do
real damage to the administrative state
the trump white house is not that white
house it just what because they just
were they got they were real real
cautious
and weren't willing to you know do the
make the changes that needed to be made
obama you think he knew how but just was
co-opted or something or obama was part
of it like obama was the administrative
state's candidate that's a way to think
of biden biden is like you know biden is
team administrative state the entire
premise of like democrat presidents is
like we will get out of the way and let
the bureaucracy do their thing
right that's that's basically how they
operate like biden's you know that's so
the idea that you have a democrat
president really do anything about the
administrative state are you kidding and
that's their base that's that's their
that's their whole
the whole premise of their electing in
the first place we had a story
several years ago that was published by
gizmodo the facebook was censoring
conservative news
because they had this trending tab and
the employees there were basically told
or had this bias conservative news
sources are fake news so they'd remove
them from trending i remember seeing
that i remember seeing people start
getting censored and banned and the
social media was manipulated
and then i said the republicans are too
stupid to solve this problem to save
their own candidacies their own
representative their own seats
now we have this from the new york post
mark zuckerberg spent
419 million dollars on non-profits ahead
of the 2020 2020 election and got out
the dem vote and they're really not very
grateful for that i don't think
they're they're you know the combination
of any trust and this you know this
francis haugen type regulation
i don't you know there's a conspiracy
theory that she's working with
facebook that she's a fake whistleblower
because she's saying everything
zuckerberg has already said people need
to understand this mark zuckerberg came
out and said please provide us with
regulation so we can deal with this now
all of a sudden a whistleblower comes
out instantly verified on twitter
oh come on and then
tomorrow i'll be in congress and then
facebook releases a statement and
guidelines about how the internet should
be censored right yeah no that i mean
they they do kind of like they would
rather be in a world where they're in
control of regulation i wouldn't be
surprised if there's like some sort of
there's some sort of collusion going on
there but that said the antitrust stuff
is no joke that that stuff is actually
going forward and and it's not helpful
to zuckerberg how are they planning that
what are they doing i mean there's
there's serious uh like there's already
you know there's they're looking at a
bipartisan law that's that's more
targeted amazon
not allowing you to preference your own
products
um they're still talking hard about
breakup and you know making facebook and
instagram and what's up divest
so what does that do
yeah i mean it's bad for zuckerberg
personally right like you know does it
do that much i don't know i mean they're
all they're all still leftist companies
i think you know it's sort of
interesting to to see it you know i mean
whenever i talk about like let's make
platform access a civil right i get the
objection from the libertarians like oh
you're using government to violate a
corporation's liberty it's like okay but
that corporation is colluding with the
government to do to violate your liberty
and i don't i don't care for
corporations are people my friend it's
amazing how it's like the democrats
became the party of mitt romney those
are usually koch brother libertarians
and a lot of them don't understand how
big tech is working with the state in
tandem making it not a private company
there's there's no argument i i don't
believe that they're private companies
there's no way not even from their start
not even from their beginning not even
what they're doing now when it comes to
the programs that they're running and
the larger participation that they have
in our political system they're not
they're not innocent corporations that
are
a part of the free capitalistic world
they're not yeah it's it's very like
it's very formalist right they're sort
of like if you know informal government
coercion is okay in the libertarian
world it seems like like you think about
think about like the vaccine mandate
debate right libertarians are like
you're violating a business's liberty if
you tell them they can't uh enforce a
vaccine mandate it's like well like look
at a company like southwest who is
clearly talking with the bite
administration regularly by
administration's going like we think
really strongly that you should impose a
vaccine mandate and they do
so basically it's like the formal
exercise of state power by a state
government saying no vaccine mandates is
like the only answer to the informal
exercise of state power by the biden
administration to persuade these
corporations to impose the mandates in
the first place i think this is why a
lot of the libertarian party doesn't
like the mises caucus because they're
getting serious about it but the the the
core of the libertarian party has always
pretty much been
we are not smart enough to recognize the
government is in control of these
corporations and therefore the
corporation should be free to do what
they do even though it's detrimental to
everybody
it's like yo libertarians should be
against centralized authority regardless
of where it comes from
right a major corporation can oppress
anybody the same as a government that's
a great way to phrase it centralized
authority is the antithesis of
libertarianism absolutely i don't
understand how you can be like
a a a naturally uh a spontaneously
formed over 200 years organization of
very powerful individuals with massive
amounts of wealth and resources
controlled an authoritarian structure is
a good thing that should be left alone
however
the same exact thing with the label on
it says government now that's where the
problem comes in it's like like it's
remarkable to me how many of these
libertarians are okay with being coerced
and and forced to walking walking off
the cliff as opposed to i should say
coerced or or manipulated into doing it
versus hard force
they're like well if the government can
or if a company convinces you to hurt
yourself that's fine no no i don't agree
that's what i mean by like overly
formalist right it's like they look at
like is this a formal exercise of
government power or not if it is bad if
it's not okay that's fine like look the
bigger picture here in my opinion is
that i mean are we really going to have
a red wave i understand historically
republicans should be in for a major
victory in the house i understand that
based on the data we're seeing there's
good signs a red wave could happen but
if mark zuckerberg is gonna dump but
have a half a billion dollars to make
sure you don't win what's he gonna do at
his own company to make sure you don't
win when it cost him nothing yeah uh i
mean he maybe he's not too happy with
the end result i mean you gotta account
for that he may not be stoked on the
antitrust thing that's true but right
like he might not spend this kind of
money again and also
man i don't know how you fix like i
think trump's sort of a unique
phenomenon where he drives that turnout
on both sides like you know he's
uniquely polarizing people love him
people hate people hate him i think
i think you look at the midterms i think
i don't know i'm i'm optimistic about
202 i think we're going to have a very
good midterm election but is it going to
be with people who are going to do
something
i mean
i think it's the only thing we can you
know
congress is never going to really do
anything the question is just stopping
democrats right like i think people
people underestimate the value of like
winning the senate for example like it
really is annoying that we didn't win
the senate um it put us in a position
where we're suddenly totally dependent
on christian cinema and joe manchin
doing our you know like
being flaky enough to do and mitt romney
right and then
like you know i mean
i don't like republicans in the in
congress that much but i know that
they're the people i can influence i
know i have zero meaningful influence
over the democratic i'm i'm i'm sick of
it man i'm i'm not gonna vote for
someone who's like i will hold the
democrats off for two years no screw off
the democrats are coming out and saying
we want to take away all your guns yes
they're saying they won't take away our
guns pay attention all these liberals
claim that's not true don't pay
attention to the laws they tried passing
when they came out and said they wanted
to ban all semi-automatic weapons which
is basically every single modern gun
okay maybe a little hyperbolic it's
almost every single gun i guess
revolvers and lever action will be okay
in bolt action no they're really trying
to do insane things and the only reason
they're not is because they're going
slow about it
i just think republicans aren't going to
do anything i think that you know
ultimately it's still worth stop you
know i basically see it as like a
defense to offense transition i still
hope you know that we can do but the
offense would happen in 2024 retaking
the white house hopefully with like an
executive branch that knows what it's
doing and that's why i'm like i you know
i'm really hoping trump doesn't run i
really really hope like we need
we need this desantis right like yeah
yeah yeah this is the guy but i don't i
i i agree because you know what ronda
santos came out and was like hey it's
columbus day and i was like yeah that's
a little thing right but that's a big
big thing in the long run it's cultural
it matters ronda santa says we're gonna
we're gonna ban you know vaccine
passports
these are big things we can see them
actually doing and so i agree if there
is a republican who says i'm i've done
these things i'm doing them and i will
do more i like that but i'm fairly
convinced in 2022 we're gonna get
republicans we're gonna sit back and say
the best we can do for you is nothing
the best democrats can do for their
constituents is burn the whole place
down now the idea of government to doing
nothing is something that i personally
like i think that should be a motive but
but i know i know we're talking about
two different things here because they
just placate us and they act and pretend
like they're going to be doing something
for us or they're going to be making a
solid stand here but let's not pretend
at the end of the day when the big money
guys come they're going to bow down uh
you know get on their knees and do
unforgiving acts for the multinational
corporations no matter how awful it is
for their constituents so i i you know
desantis is interesting because he is
kind of throwing a wrench into a lot of
the narratives and agenda he's the one
that really did by himself stand up
against the lockdown stand up against a
lot of the mandates a lot of the
restrictions and i think if it wasn't
for him a lot of other people would have
just followed in line and and complied
and obeyed and i think florida was the
first state that said no enough is
enough and and desantis just made a
statement also just a few moments ago
talking about the vaccine mandates where
he said quote the coercion is just
totally wrong i think it's destroying
trust and public health you're going to
end up driving people away and he's
making some good solid logic solid
logical points that i think are
deserving to be considered there's two
things
i i would love to see uh ron desantis uh
presidential run i i don't know if i
support him completely because i've only
seen the culture war things that he's
done but we got to see hard policy stuff
too
um
but we're hearing that his wife uh has
cancer oh yeah that's another product
yeah and so it may be that he he doesn't
run yeah that's that's that's true but
the other thing too is what what i've
been told and i remember who told us
this
the reason he's so upped up to um you
know up to date on the mod like the of
the current political crisis and culture
war is because of his wife because she
pays attention because she she follows
the news and she follows the cultural
issues and then they sort of work
together and then it keeps him more
informed i'd have to imagine that you
know a governor is actively trying to
maintain fundraising and do all this
political paperwork having a good
partner like that like his wife helping
him stay informed so someone told us
that they said that she's really really
well versed on these issues and that's
his edge yeah they're they're a good
team um but i mean i i give you know
credit like whenever i've seen him talk
about something like he not only did he
do the vaccine mandate stuff he was one
of the first people to get a big tech
law passed and signed a like anti-big
tech censorship law i think he did texas
recently did one too and the florida
they knocked him down they knocked him
down at in court but like he got it
passed right right that's that's still
impressive and he understands like the
salience and importance of the issue
and he was and he was ahead of the curve
on that i just trump trump ain't it yeah
like relative i mean and then you know
again we talked about the cockpit right
like ronnie sanders is going to come in
and he's not going to be dependent on
his lawyers to tell him what his powers
are he's going to be able to read the
you know his needle understand it
himself and like push the limits like
that's why i think obama was so
effective in so many ways is because
obama was a lawyer right and a
constitutional lawyer so
he he understood his office and he
understood exactly what where he could
push when he needed to pull back and as
a result like you know not i don't mean
effective in terms of like moral virtue
but merely effective in terms of
achieving democrat politics i don't want
to i don't want a president who will be
like a candidate of owning the libs you
know i want to see some legitimate
policies but i imagine he's going to be
for many of the policies i think would
probably be good i imagine he'd do
school choice and things like that i'd
be interested to see his foreign policy
though because i think that'll be big
and one of my concerns is that we get a
rising star who's you know culture war
freedom you know side but then he turns
out to still just be pro-war
establishment in the long run shoot and
you know at this point i just i really
don't want to lose the culture war
anymore it's really it really is
annoying um you know if i can't you know
i feel like we have had a pretty big sea
change in the republican party on
foreign policy thanks to trump in a lot
of ways and i'm very grateful to the
former president for that
but you know i really you know i i think
even if desantis isn't perfect on
foreign policy like or sorry
culture
culture war is a game that no one can
win either we stop playing or we're all
going to lose technically you know we we
lose in the way where it's a net
negative across the board but the issue
is lose by how much
well the longer we play the worst
opponents to come into this negotiating
table right but there's like the problem
is with like the joe rogan thing sanjay
gupta wrote this essay which is
ridiculous and he's saying like i was
warned joe rogan's a bad faith actor
like listen
we we're gonna i want to save the sanjay
gupta stuff but i'll just say this sanji
gupta says in his essay he's never had a
conversation with someone that's that
was three hours or longer and that to me
was like getting smacked in the face
with a baseball bat like
sanjay gupta never had a conversation
with someone over three hours how old is
this guy is he not married
it was crazy for me to hear this but
these people live in a world where they
don't communicate they just get their
news from the tv
i'm like my whole life sitting around
with my friends in chicago playing star
wars out to the republic for like four
or five hours we're just talking about
space-time and they were stoned out of
their minds but like these conversations
were crazy and in-depth in politics and
we'd be fact-checking things we're just
having fun exploring ideas he's never
done that a neurosurgeon writer medical
reporters got his head in the books he's
been in the books probably his whole
life so they're he's wrapped up in this
different world now i want to pull up
the story because i'll tell you this
with with the zuckerberg thing the the
one i i i agree with you uh we need to
win the culture war and i will say this
one of the reasons i probably just
outright vote for renaissance is that he
went after big tech in any way
we have this story
if you head over to instagram and take a
look at mr luke we are change that's his
uh his his instagram handle is at luke
we are change if you try to follow him
and please do you may be greeted with
this message it says are you sure you
want to follow luke we are change this
account has repeatedly posted false
information that was reviewed by
independent fact checkers or went
against our community guidelines i
unfollowed luke and followed him back
and i got that message yeah prove it you
sobs what fake news i i post highly
sophisticated intelligent
thought-provoking memes with like 3d 4d
level chess i mean can can you pull up
my my just some of the things i post on
there especially the george george w
bush one because because if they go
after that one they're admitting that
they're a part of wrong think uh be
because of the pfizer one up there again
and
all i post right all i post is it's like
segments from here my shirts and memes i
i love to go to dave chappelle to to
post memes about you know curious things
that make people critically think about
the issues it's not even facts
well that's a shirt no fake news that's
a real shirt and and i have one one
shirt that's censored and it's scribbled
that says tax this d and i have another
shirt that's not censored and you could
get that on the bus the best political
shows
but i can't say it here but i mean look
what i post i i i post stuff like joe
biden leaving office in 2024. how can
you fact check that
how can you
do you have a magic
time machine that you could say he's
definitely lying this needs to be fact
checked number one what's the fact
checks tell me tell me what what i got
wrong through these joe biden
okay but you know what i don't know stop
losing this is top fake news don't you
dare photo don't you dare you sign up
with a gun this phone no it's not joe
biden here we go it is an old man in
front of a burning car and it is not joe
how do you know joe biden's not going to
look like that in two in three years i
guess i get it so so
so again and then and another thing
who's fact-checking me let me let you
know
let's let's call a spade a spade here
put out your name put what organization
who's behind it and and what exactly do
you have problems with with posts like
this tell me right now and they won't we
had we had james o'keefe
and we were talking about stanford put
out a story claiming that
james o'keefe
me tim poole
sidney powell and lynn wood and some
other people were like the biggest
purveyors of
voter misinformation or whatever
and
and i'm like what did james tweet about
anything he he like he posts veritas
stories where they literally have
undercover things on other people and
what do i post on twitter like i post i
think i posted a picture of a hairless
rabbit once i post stories all of it's
news guard certified and the best part
is
trump supporters got extremely mad at me
for saying there was no widespread voter
fraud the entire time i've been saying
that i even said it to steve bannon when
he came on the show i was like ben i
disagree i think we look at that story
from mark zuckerberg you take a look at
the laws being changed i think that this
is you know it's pulling people off off
base because the democrats have
excellent ground game and they put out
fake news
for some reason and then of course
people are like well if stanford said it
it must be true and they put it on
wikipedia and then it becomes fast or
cnn telling everyone that it's you know
horse dewormer uh there's so many lies
by the mainstream media and you know
anderson cooper all these other you know
professional fake news spreaders all
these professional propagandists they
get to do whatever they want on these
big tech social media companies they you
know but also i was criticizing
instagram and facebook really hard over
the mental health issues a couple days
ago uh specifically also on the show and
i was making my own videos about this on
my own youtube channel i was going after
them hard detailing the the
psychological experiments that they'd
done on unsuspecting users so so this
seems more vindictive than anything else
because you look at the posts i make
they're silly they're ridiculous they're
they're over the top i i you know i told
people i don't even care i'm just gonna
post ridiculous stuff on instagram if it
gets taken down it gets taken down and a
couple a couple days ago i said tim
laughing it's a japan one yeah
it's real
you know these memes
check these for those that are listening
it says npr accuses dave chappelle of
using white privilege and then below it
is dave chappelle as clayton bixby the
black white supremacist and it says good
for nothing tricksters he's blind in
that bottom picture
well this is from his own skit where he
was pretending to be a black kkk member
uh
and a racist against black people who
was black himself but didn't know
because he was blind and the kkk handed
him around and he was good friends with
them and they were like yeah we're just
not going to tell them because this is
pretty funny
a couple weeks ago i posted on september
16th hey some because something weird
happened i i was i was doing okay on my
instagram before before i came here on
this show my numbers were rising pretty
well and i was getting a lot of
interaction i was getting a lot of views
and then out of nowhere it stopped and i
was getting a one-tenth of my engagement
and then for for weeks it was the same
one-tenth and i'm like what's happening
here so i i put a post hey this is a
test instagram has been
has been limiting our post to more than
10 of our followers if you see this
click like and tell me that you see this
in your timeline they fact check it they
said this is fake news it's incorrect
even though and the analytics show uh uh
9 10 drop in audience interaction
suddenly without me changing anything or
changing any way that i post or interact
with audience members so they they're
even fact checking saying that it's
false that they're limiting me to my
audience which they clearly are through
the analytics through the numbers uh and
it's this is the world that we're living
in right now where where memes like this
you know memes memes
that again
i'm not making any stance here i'm not
telling people what to do here i'm just
trying to make people laugh and think a
little bit um and for them to target
this is ridiculous and absolutely a sham
a huge injustice and
ridiculous to say the least just as
ridiculous as the memes i mean the
george w bush one that i posted we don't
have to show it here but but if they
flag that one that means that they're
committing wrong think all right that's
how that's that's the level of
sophistication of meme warfare that we
have going on here that that again is
extremely important
i remember first coming on the show i
said memes are going to be
the thing that are going to change the
landscape of our political dichotomy i i
really do truly believe in them and i
think that's why they're going after
satire now which i said you know they're
going to figure out how to go after
satire i think this is the first step in
that direction they've been they've been
doing this that this is why they had to
ban the donald because memes
got trump elected yeah maybe maybe not
like the core of his platform but it
gave him the bump he needed
magic man have you seen that documentary
on me magic no it's like a it's like a
youtube documentary somebody made but
it's really really interesting how they
go through like the history of cac and
like the frog and pepe and the weird
stuff on 4chan and they're like me magic
man but whether or not you believe in
magic when you have people who have
found a way to have fun
and build community and then all of a
sudden everyone's laughing with each
other and sharing jokes
that's going to help that person out
yeah and i'm not even like promoting
anything i'm not even telling people
what to do i'm just saying hey this this
is a stupid ridiculous government policy
let's laugh about it that's it i'm not
even saying do this or get involved or
don't do this i'm not even doing any of
that on instagram so my response to this
is uh
uh
you know family friendly show uh screw
you instagram uh everyone follow me
archangel and uh just in case
they take me down uh go check out enough
of censorship.com which is a link to my
email list which makes me uncensorable
no matter what happens so that's my
response my official statement to
instagram or anybody asking about this
story that's officially what i got to
say screw you instagram uh let let's
make sure that this policy doesn't work
it's ridiculous and i want to thank the
the people who were sending me this
because i wouldn't have noticed uh you
know no one told me this i never got a
warning i never got a notification uh
they didn't tell me anything and just
sporadically i just see my viewership go
down within the last few weeks and it's
just it's just weird and strange that
we're living in this world where you
know you could be convicted of wrong
think and then have your actions
yeah not even know but also have your
access to people that you're that are
your friends and are part of your
community taken away from you uh just
because some fact checker whoever that
random mysterious person is decided that
he doesn't like your humor yeah it's
almost like this should be against the
law okay that would be really what i'm
thinking of this is like them making an
editorial claim on your content
standing behind it like a platform or
like a publisher rather uh which we i
had a long conversation with section 230
last night and about
editing section 230 basically fixing it
so that
maybe companies that make editorial
claims like this account is responsible
for x
then become considered publishing news
but but we don't even have to argue that
hold on will take it away so like here's
i actually you know there's two parts of
it right there's the making the weird
little editorial claim about you luke
right which is the most hilarious thing
because it's like it either is fake or
it violates our community guidelines
we're not going to tell you which one
like you know lawyers would laugh at
that right it's stupid but and then
there's the actual throttling now if it
weren't for the throttling i think this
if anything would make you more popular
because it's such an obviously
ridiculous way to try and indict someone
they've said some things that are false
based on someone saying they were false
we're not going to tell you what was
false who determined it like it would
just it would be bs it's the throttling
that's the problem and so it's like it's
like those twitter notifications when
they put them on like i don't think
those are a big problem it's the
algorithmic throttling that is is really
wrong and so
you know it's hard to say anything about
the you know when they make these
statements they are speaking right and i
i think that they do have a first
amendment right to speak if they want to
put stuff at the bottom of my tweets
that's their right if they're they're
constraining my ability to reach my
audience then they're censoring and
that's different and i don't think they
have a guaranteed first amendment right
to censor people does the first
amendment check out in private
companies like this though
so uh the first amendment this is
actually an interesting area of the law
like the question is
can a state or government give
additional protect first amendment
rights or additional speech rights to
their citizens on private platforms
right and the answer to that the the
case that's closest
um is a case about
is called pre-new york shopping center
it's based on a california question
about whether people had the right to
petition in shopping malls basically
like there was a state law in california
that said or california supreme court
decision that said our citizens have the
right to petition in in shopping malls
as a first amendment right under our
california constitution
and the shopping mall owner's like but
that's a violation of my first amendment
rights like i don't want to be associ i
have a freedom of association right i
don't want to be associated with
uh the this random petitioner it's also
you know free free speech right i have
the right to censor like etcetera and
the supreme court is like no no you
don't no one's associating you to speech
you have the ability to say what you
want to say
um
and as a result your speech rights
aren't implicated so
it's perfectly acceptable for a state to
give private consumers you know private
individuals the repetition on your
property i think you know you're not
performing any editorial function nobody
thinks you are so facebook and twitter
in the same position they're not
performing any equal editorial function
they're they have seven million people i
think we need to uh i mentioned this to
james o'keefe
on wikipedia
the article about project veritas is
just the most insane garbled lies far
right disinformation organization and i
said to him i was like james what's it
say on top of the article it says from
wikipedia
it doesn't say from you know cow
you know finger 93
it doesn't say it's from you know ian
the cow finger or 97 it says it's from
wikipedia and if wikipedia is taking the
byline on this one aren't they
responsible for that speech presented on
that platform
another thing to really kind of
entertain here is one of the things that
made the internet so amazing so
wonderful was the free access to whoever
you wanted to follow you followed
someone you saw their content it was
incredible it was amazing we don't have
that anymore you follow someone you may
see their stuff you may not see their
stuff there's a carefully curated
algorithm that has long-term
psychological negative effects on the
population that is rising suicide levels
that is rising self-hurt incidences that
is rising levels of depression that is
rising the levels of psychological
disorders and this is because now
they're carefully curating what
information you get to hear and not hear
i mean and and that decision should be
up to a human being saying i want to
follow him i want to i want to see what
he posts if if you're not following them
you shouldn't be send said stuff that
that you don't want to see but right now
if you look at instagram a lot of the
stuff is forced on your news feed you
look at the facebook news feed you look
at twitter instagram now says like these
three posts are recent after that i'm
scrolling and it's random and i'm like
wait i don't follow these people yeah
and then you gotta click see older posts
to actually get the people you follow
now so this is sinister on so many
different levels because people actively
want to follow me want to find my
content they're denied that by using
this platform so that's another level of
interacting of of intervening in
something that was free was awesome gave
people what they wanted because people
were sick sick of being lectured to
people were sick of being lied to people
were sick of just being force-fed
nonsense now we're back to the day and
age where their force fed nonsense every
single day while restricting the small
and independent voices that made them as
popular as they are regarding the uh the
shopping mall metaphor if would the
shopping mall then be allowed to put up
a sign like the petitioners over there
the shopping mall have a sign says
petitioners that way lying about it
could they do that and could they have a
sign that said
liar pointing at the petitioners
the latter sure right like that that's a
speech right you know like again they're
on their own property they have the
right to speak and say these people are
lunatics who are going to hell who knows
right um and then on the but on the the
first one decept like deceiving then
that might be thwarting the underlying
right to speak which is a little so you
could argue that do changing the
algorithm without their knowledge is a
form of deceit right i think i think
that you could i think that it it poses
a very interesting question about
whether or not a state could itself have
imposed kind of regulations on the
algorithm it's it's it's trickier
because it gets that's a little closer
speech like you're forcing them to
organize the information that appears on
the feedback what would be nice is if
you could force them to show at least
how they're organizing it by displaying
the algorithmic code sure is is there an
argument to make here about the
manipulation of the news feed that is
creating self-harm and psychological
disorders because there are medical
studies that are showing that you know
if you show certain images you do have a
certain psychological effect on a human
being
and i think there's a lot of correlation
with social media use and you know
depression suicide everything that i
talked about before is there even some
kind of room in court to maneuver to say
this social media caused actual real
life harm well i mean you have that you
you can't one there's you can't prohibit
you can't force people to speak right
that's par part of the first amendment
is you don't have the you don't have you
can't force people that's compelled
speech that's also first amendment
violation so that's part one um part two
is
that you know there are specific
categories of the law that are where
speech is unlawful defamation right yeah
um so is this considered defamation um
what is is what considered definition
them saying i i spread fake news
not any examples without any i mean it
has to be
provably false right and and you have to
prove under current law you have to
prove actual malice right which means
that they're knowingly lying i would
love a jury to see my memes
yeah that's actually like but then they
say it might violate our community
guidelines which community guidelines
well we you know they they get then they
get the entire they can look at their
entire terms of service and be like aha
this was inflammatory and i'm sure they
would say that wasn't actually joe biden
on the mean that said this is just
how do you know look there's not 2024.
look at because the jury will agree and
be like yeah that's not joe biden and
then they'll say cr our statement was
true he said it was joe biden the the
whether or not someone understands it's
a joke or not is not on you know us when
we say some people won't get it
so like here's the thing like that the
reason that statement that they preview
you they say like you've posted fake
news or false news as determined by
independent fact checkers and and or you
violated community guidelines not
specifying how it's fake what it is or
what news that's lawyered right because
that's vague it is a very very vague
criticism it literally could go either
way it doesn't even actually accuse you
necessarily of having put out anything
fake so
um as a result like when you make a
really vague lawyered statement like
that it's almost impossible to prove
falsity okay
and so that's that would which is a
necessary element of any definition i
want to talk to you guys about why
independent media is so important and
why these uh these stories here are are
so just uh so awful the censorship what
they did to crowder um i think you know
what happened with crowder getting
suspen suspended and getting a strike is
particularly worrisome it's another
greatest hand in the heat and we'll
consider this to be a semi terrible
segue into the story about joe rogan and
sanjay gupta but uh joe rogan sits down
with sanjay gupta of cnn and refuses to
let sanjay gupta change the subject he
says why did your network lie
about what the medication i was taking
was they said it was horse dewormer and
joe's like a doctor prescribed it to me
and sanjay goop is like you're right
you're right okay they shouldn't have
said it
that's the power of independent media
and joe rogan may be on spotify or
whatever but that's why they don't like
it that's why they censor it now i
really want to point something out
though
in this article from cnn.com dr sanjay
gupta why joe rogan and i sat down and
talked for more than three hours there
are two very important things that give
you insight into the minds of the cult
and boy when i read you these things
will you realize it's a cult first and
foremost he says
i don't think i ever had a conversation
that long with anyone seriously think
about that we sat in a windowless
podcast booth with two sets of
headphones and microphones and a few
feet between us not a single
interruption no cell phones no
distractions no bathroom breaks
um show of hands or actually let's go
will have you ever had a conversation
with someone that was at least three
hours
yeah i mean if you know with breaks in
between but yes like i'd say you know i
mean it's the kind of thing where
convert you know like you're in a car i
have been on the show we've never gone
three hours though we do way more than
that yeah have we have well it's two and
a
half
and then we start the show at eight we
end at ten yeah we've definitely talked
okay so we have talked from around three
hours
sort of like but even with friends
throughout your life one-on-one yeah
like conversations before yeah say
you're in a car ride with somebody right
right a long car ride like you'll be
talking with them over the course of a
lengthy period of time yes yes road
trips hold on luke have you had a
conversation oh yeah of course uh lydia
yeah many many many many times yeah 100
especially like the ones they have face
to face going at it for three plus hours
yes i would imagine ian's the one person
was probably the longest conversation
with people out of any of us because
you've seen the kind of guy who's going
to sit there and really just like hang
out with people in a sauna and he was
pre-cell phone
yeah yeah i went to theater school it's
all about communication this is a guy
who is telling you think about that he's
never had a conversation that was three
hours look that maybe it's just me maybe
most people really don't interact with
humans that much i just that's shocking
to me and so i see that i'm like this is
a guy who doesn't actually communicate
with people he sits in a room reads a
book and watches a tv and doesn't talk
to other people but here is you ready
for this one the best part he says
okay
when i told joe early in the podcast
that i didn't agree with his apparent
views on vaccines against covet i've
acted in many things in between part of
me thought the mma former taekwondo
champion might hurtle himself across the
table and throttle my neck but instead
he smiled and off we went
yeah that's a weird bias that you have
like here's a guy he is the chief
medical correspondent for cnn the most
trusted name of news who has never had a
conversation with someone that lasted at
least three hours and genuinely feared
joe rogan would physically assault him
in a podcast studio
over his opinions that's what that's
when he could depose him i mean
basically that's what this is and or
he's lying he's just he's lying you know
it's something interesting like people
there's certain people and there's only
a few areas where like it's one thing to
have a conversation with someone over a
long period of time it's another to like
be able to to be interrogated right and
by that i mean like to be asked a
continuous sequence of questions to
examine what you think in your position
on something that happens in law school
right if you're the subject of a
socratic questioning from a professor
um that'll happen in debate rounds like
there's cross exam cross examination
that takes a period like there's other
things but there's a lot of people even
if they're very smart and they've gone
through very high level
you know academia or like medical school
or something will have never actually
been in a position where they were
subject to like a sustained line of
questioning about their beliefs and i
think that's sanjay if anything i think
that's probably what he's expressing
this like i was not ready this is like
the first time i've ever been
interrogated like i mean i don't mean to
target like with like law enforcement
but just like questioned about a
position for this length of a period of
time and and it's the sort of you know
regret kicking in because he got owned
right like he got revealed that he had
to get up and basically he had to
concede to sound like a reasonable
person that yes in fact cnn had done
wrong here um and then cnn is now so
furious about it that they're putting
him back on the show to like justify
yeah i i i just got i got a request i i
would i would i would um greatly
appreciate it joe if you could just
take some money
drop it in a retainer for some good law
firm and sue cnn
lemon has come out denied cnn lied about
joe rogan's covet treatment after
claiming the podcaster took horse
dewormer no joke they doubled down on
the fact that multiple hosts lied
joe rogan sat there in front of sanjay
gupta and said a doctor prescribed me
medication sanjay said yes they
shouldn't have said that then when
sanjay gupta goes on with don lemon he
does not correct don lemon when don says
no no listen listen it is horse dewormer
don lemon should go on joe rogan don't
be a little whiny you know he never will
of course not he doesn't you know you
couldn't sustain that sanjay gupta is
smarter than this is why this was this
is why this was so fascinating this is
why this video went so viral because
this was finally someone a part of the
establishment being sat down and talked
to like a regular human being without
any teleprompters without any scripts or
any agenda and he stuttered and he
messed up and he tried to get away from
the subject and joe was right on him and
he stumbled someone wrote a very funny
comment under this entire story saying
it's it's a very strange world when an
mma commentator stumps a medical doctor
on the topic of medicine and let's be
honest here joe rogan was absolutely
right to call out sanjay gupta the chief
medical advisor of cnn why he didn't
intervene step up or at least correct
the record when cnn was blatantly lying
about him and spreading dangerous
medical disinformation that would have
real life consequences that probably did
have real life consequences let's just
be honest here about this particular
topic sanjay gumta didn't have an answer
didn't he tried to change the topic he
was like yeah maybe not like i want to
talk about this and joko's no no no no
no no let's get to this issue because
this is an important issue and then
sanjay admitted that the main reason he
went on this show was because he was
trying to get joe to get vaccinated now
this is another layer to this that we
need to kind of kind of unravel here
because he admitted i want joe to get
vaccinated that's why i went on the show
that's that's his that's that's his
explanation to all of his establishment
buddies that are like what the hell did
you do you let the mask off your face
you showed us the true reality of being
stumped by him and and he's saying no no
i just wanted him to get vaccinated why
the man just went through covet he has
natural immunity there's many scientific
studies and preliminary findings that
are showing that natural immunity could
last a lifetime why still on top of that
are you telling him to get vaccinated it
makes absolutely no point and there have
been a number of complications and a
number of medical professionals saying
if you do have strong antibodies and
natural immunity you might have
complications from the vaccine so again
not a medical doctor not telling people
what to do here but sanjay gupta
admittedly came into this already trying
to push bogus information that that
wasn't helpful at all and and joe rogan
just blatantly called him out on all of
his bull crap and he did not have an
answer to it at all i think i got a lot
of respect for sanji for going on there
wanting to go on there doing it
and and just pushing he tweeted it out
he wasn't trying to hide from it and
they talked about like sanjay used to be
very anti-marijuana and then started to
realize when he started to see the
studies he's a books guys in the books
all the time when he sees the evidence
he changed his position he realized that
kids that were having like tremors i
remember that a few years ago this was a
long time ago when marijuana was still a
taboo thing where they weren't talking
about the benefits of thc and cbd he
went to amsterdam and interviewed small
children and actually i was surprised by
his work at that time so it's very
interesting that you're bringing this up
and and you you do bring up a good point
that at least he did go on and at least
we saw the the mask fall off slip for a
little bit but he's going to get
punished he's already on an apology tour
all over cnn saying yeah you guys were
right yeah you guys were right when in
reality no they weren't they absolutely
weren't let's be honest to to again
double down and say no this was a
medicine for horses bull crap remember
when that cnn hosts cannibalized uh
human yeah that's on youtube by the way
that's fine for you the cannibal raza
aslan yes right who it's accurate to
describe as a cannibal because it's
accurate who went crazy afterwards he
did he did my own so reza oslon uh was
hosting this show on on cnn and my
understanding is before the show he was
like relatively normal he was a
religious scholar and i know people who
know him like i have i have friends of
mine who know him and
i i wonder if that that episode where he
ate human brain it was a small piece of
charred human brain
after that it's like he's just insane
the things he posts on twitter like he's
aggravated i wonder if he got like some
kind of shakes from eating human brain
you get like prion diseases man yeah
protein folds yeah yeah yeah yeah and
also the stress of being called a
cannibal over and over he is a
counterfeit was was a cannibal is he
still practicing it doesn't matter if he
was like if you kill once once a
cannibal always a cannibal
no it is though if you choose to kill
someone you're a murderer right well if
you used to be a soccer player and now
you're not you're not still a soccer
player
if if there's a way to like if you're
used to murder and now you don't you're
still considered a murderer exactly but
not a soccer player you are a cannibal
it's like well but to be fair it was a
long time ago so
i think cam to be a cannibal
i got to be honest
i got to be honest if you played soccer
in college and then you stopped playing
i'd still say it's fair to say you're a
soccer soccer player
like you're gonna know all about it
you're gonna know this you're gonna have
retained skills and you'll be able to
pick it up more than anyone else i would
say i was a soccer player if i don't
play at all anymore i was
so i don't that stress of ben being like
you're a cannibal and he's like dude i
did it once and they're like you're okay
that's like you never want to be in that
[ __ ] time
every once in a while dude it's all dude
it's like it's like it's like
with with murder if you choose to kill a
person you're a murderer and it's like
yeah but that was a long time ago and i
only did it one time it's like i don't
care like you're a murderer i just
committed one murder yeah that's just
one just one
and some people do sanjay also made a
very uh interesting point that a lot of
people are talking about right now when
he was on the joe rogan podcast because
he admitted that the aim on the show
when he was talking to joe rogan that
the aim of vaccinating children isn't to
protect them it's to quote slow the
spread and protect adults around them
and if that's the official justification
if that's the official science of what
doctors and cnn and
the establishment medical professionals
are standing on they're pretty much
putting young people at risk for the
benefit of the old and if that's
happening in the society that's a clear
sign of a decay in society luke but
clearly dr sanjay gupta is not a smart
person but that's my own words i didn't
end saying it not me
no of course of course i'm saying let's
just say this then if that is the
official uh line from sanjay gupta which
is clearly in in
contradictoring the the establishment
narrative then sanjay gupta must be a
[ __ ] he must just be a crackpot
conspiracy theorist peddling medical
disinformation i i don't know i mean i
think like we were talking about earlier
it's like i have the same respect for
sanjay gupta that i would have for some
novice debater who got smoked in like a
round you're like well at least you
tried you know
like you got beat really bad but you
shouldn't need to have a debate with
with with joe the problem is that
like it wasn't even a debate joe was
cordial to him he was nicely talking to
him he wasn't he wasn't aggressive oh oh
and and in sanjay gupta's article he
says he gifted joe a joe rogan
experience face mask from joe's own
website which joe seemed surprised by
and he makes it seem like
joe rogan who's anti-mask i bought him a
mask from himself and he was shocked and
i'm like he was probably confused as to
why you got him a mask from his own
merch store
someone showed up he was like hey tim i
got you something what is it it's one of
your own shirts i'd be like we have a
pile over there yeah
i guess i appreciate it the
self-righteousness and delusion i mean
wow and these are the people preaching
these people never get outside of their
bubbles and this is the first time that
they do and they get smoked as you're
saying that's a good so so so this is
you know i mean cnn never has anyone who
doesn't push the narrative in an agenda
never on they never have those
discussions they're they're living in a
world that is tightly controlled the
information that they get is carefully
curated for them and they just know one
particular thing they don't know
anything else so we're talking to
individuals that are literally uh the
hell and colors of our society
he strikes me as highly intelligent but
ignorant in ways and i can say that from
experience because when i'm on this show
i tend to be very ignorant about what
we're talking about because i don't
study and read about it but this is not
about it on the spot
i'm able to process the information yeah
so the ability to defend your own
position from a hostile interrogator
right or inquisitor is like learned and
it also require if you're not used to it
your car is a lot more work not if
you're on cnn no no not if you're honest
not if you're not if you're um um
mentally capable and i'll give a shout
out to jordan peterson that that
interview he did with jim jeffries where
he says yo should people be compelled to
use the pronouns and then peterson's
like no you know people should not be
compelled to speak and then he's like a
private business shouldn't be forced to
do this that or otherwise and then
jeffrey says do you think that the
government enforcing desegregation was a
good idea and then peter went hmm
maybe i was wrong about that
very true
as a mature adult who's in control of
his emotions was just like oh
yeah maybe i'm wrong yeah yeah that's
that's also true that's a very similar
like i'm thinking i guess more along the
ways of getting through something like
that without having to make a concession
that you were wrong right you actually
have to think through it very in very in
great detail and nuance your position my
point is if you're wrong you should just
be like well you know maybe i was wrong
about it look like sanjay knew his job
was on the line like remember when i
told zubi he was wrong when he said
vitamin and i was like it's vitamin
boy
yeah we're wrong sometimes i'm wrong
sometimes too but it's about being able
to admit it that that sets you aside
from the mainstream media that's the
difference they live in a totally smoke
up your
family-friendly show tuckus
world
um
and then we live in a world where we
have to you know go through comments we
actually i mean i'm reading the comments
right now i love you yeah i mean you
guys are interesting to see the latest
yeah if you see me laughing here it's
because of the comments wait wait wait
let me let me let me um this is a good
this is a good point to bring up bring
up something you know yeah we want to
make sure we're getting things right we
have a bunch of people in the chat who
will say like your correction yesterday
we did a correction on our segment on
crowder i misinterpreted what was going
on with the suspension but he was
suspended i want to show you this story
from cnn business and i want to give a
special shout out to one of the most
evil people in media brian stelter yes
cnn writes this article these four words
are helping spread vaccine
misinformation
four little words do your own research
are hurting the u.s pandemic response
cnn's chief media correspondent brian
stelter said on reliable sources now
this story is from last month but i
think it's very important because brian
selter also
had a segment where he said
don't go and watch the propaganda come
to us
that's how you know you're being lied to
because i tell you this make sure you go
and watch cnn you understand their point
of view make sure you're watching you
know progressives and conservatives so
you get a healthy diet of perspective
and then figure out what you think is
right for you why i'm not an
authoritarian and i think most people
come on the show some people are
authorities but most people aren't and
so what that means is it's up to you to
figure out what works for you and what
you believe
cnn is authoritarian they're evil they
want to keep you in the dark so that you
serve them they literally told you
reading wikileaks was illegal
they literally came out on national
television fight for us because we're
journalists but but you chris is a
lawyer too he has a law degree exactly
oh it's like the first amendment thing
remember that famous thing where he's
like who said a protest needs to be
peaceful and then ramen bro was just
like it's right there in the first
amendment you got to look it up
listening and believing are different
and you want to listen with skepticism
to as much as you can jacinda arden is
she the prime minister of uh new zealand
new zealand we are your only source of
truth yeah yeah this is like from a week
ago a video of her on twitter i saw it's
so disturbing that she's telling people
do not listen to these other sources do
not pay attention to them we are only
listen to us we are the arby's something
happened to the like sort of wealthy
white liberal mind right i i don't know
why that is but like
you know i basically i look at australia
and new zealand and i'm like this is
what it would be like if the wealthy
white liberals were running were
completely controlled this country right
if the democratic party didn't have you
know a big part of its constituency is
like minorities like if it were just
white democrats we would be like
australia and new zealand yep guarantee
it yep
so uh we can every day just um you know
give your respects to the right-wing nut
jobs living in the mountains for helping
keep this country uh balanced i guess
i'm kidding by the way but i mean we do
have a lot better than other places like
you know
some people often are like man this i've
seen something like america has going
crazy i'm like if you want to see crazy
like there are there are much worse
places to be it was so crazy what she
said to an american well check this out
we have it we have it here in america
lydia just pulled this article up from
the new york times don't go down the
rabbit hole hold on hold on get ready
for this
critical thinking as we are taught to do
it isn't helping in the fight against
misinformation
please
okay brian selter is telling people
don't do your own research the new york
times is saying don't think critically
all right
it's like ethan klein said you don't
even have to think about it you just go
on the website and it tells you what to
do
congratulations well they want little
peasant slaves and they're doing the pr
bidding of the ruling establishment that
wants to control them more and have
every uh aspect of their lives carefully
coordinated in a way that directly
benefits them this is exactly what
they
they're
doing
sophisticated people
well they think they could fool everyone
and they have absolute disrespect for
the general public that's why they lie
to them continually that's why they're
they're pushing this other nonsense onto
people and you know for some people uh
they're not wrong but for the majority
of people uh i i believe they're totally
wrong and a lot of people saying hey
they're telling me not to do my own
homework they're telling me not to do my
own research they're telling me not to
critically
look to be fair
when they say not to do your own
research they're helping you because as
we know it would be illegal right you
know chris cuomo it was cuomo said that
yeah about weekly like we can look at
these documents because
see now what if you went you did your
own research and you broke the law luke
don't think critically well just go to
the just go to the government's website
the fbi hasn't trapped people for less
um already so
you know maybe you're not even wrong to
be honest with you but but again this
just shows you that the complete
pr representation that the media really
is they're not journalists they're not
the mainstream media they're just
spokespersons for the super rich that
are trying to placate you pacify you and
make you comply with every crazy demand
that they have for you maybe some
valuable if they had rephrased this and
said like don't believe everything you
read at face value look deeper no no no
no do critical thinking maybe then it
would make if they had the opposite
message of what they had now maybe then
you can make an argument you're telling
people to think critically of course
you're telling them they're telling
people to do the opposite and either
they're not either they're idiotically
conflating the the the definition of
thinking critically and don't believe
everything you see at face value or
they're blatantly
attempting to mislead people to become
like a slaughter maybe ian is is a
secret establishment she'll be forcing
him
because
well well
i'm going to say this but i'm being fair
you are post-modernist and you often
placate the things they're doing and try
to find justifications as if they're
doing something good uh 2006 i started
making youtube videos they contacted me
october 2006.
so that's a joke by the way
[Laughter]
i mean postmodernism is a way to
critique all this stuff like once you
understand what they're doing like you
start you start reading you know
foucault is like one of the classic
lefty thinkers but a big part of
foucault's work is about biopolitics
like the management of a human
population's health that seems really
relevant right about now honestly i went
through a hard post-modernist phase
where i started to think like that from
like 2006 to 2008 and it's there's video
evidence of it if you want to watch it
on youtube it was pretty crazy but
having gone through it i can now see the
pitfalls as if i'm experiencing what
they're experiencing it helps and
sometimes i'll bring that up on the show
and it's really kind of out of place on
this show because we're talking more
about like literally you know people
don't understand too i think i think
we'll we can do the the big you know
reveal
uh ian actually you know he normally
wears a suit i'm taking my shirt off
he normally he normally wears a suit
and he walks around with his hair done
up very properly
and he's got a british accent i do two
hours this is uh we hired an actor and
we were like we need a hippie stoner you
know um thanks for doing my makeup
beforehand too by the way it's just dirt
[Laughter]
it's a wig yeah that's true
i don't know how much longer we'll uh
we'll will last in this world right in
politics well look what happens with
stephen crowder yeah he does a comedy
bit on a news story and they come after
him and now there's a big story he can't
talk about and you know
censorship is real we set up we we may
have uh you know timcast.com and we're
working really hard we're growing free
damastan is now um in in the in the
ownership of the tim cast media
growing conglomerate which means we're
going to be doing more culture content
more gun content we're going to be
having like range stuff training and you
know maybe even some cqc training stuff
uh so we're growing we're definitely
growing and we want we want to teach
people responsibility we want to inspire
people to to take care of themselves to
think critically
but
you know we're still walking on thin ice
we're still traversing you know flaming
field at any moment we could be
you know cut back severely it could make
it very very difficult to try and defend
our ideals and our our
i think of it as a metaphor of like
we're streaming swimming upstream and
that's the political situation we're all
trying to swim upstream together then
when we get to the where we're going
that's there's all these other fish
there and this is the culture and we're
all kind of competing to get through but
then there's the gate of the dam and
that's the technology that we use and
unless we control the technology that
we're using there's no way to get up
through that dam to get upstream any
further
so that's why we're building the verse
out it's it's not just technology and
it's infrastructure right so the
technology that's being built out with
the the the metaverse project i think
you you can call it is its
infrastructure
creating pathways for people to maintain
communications to persist as the likes
of cnn the new york times try to curtail
your ability to think
or or literally tell you not to
and those are the people promoted those
are the people in the in the algorithms
those are the people in your news feeds
those are the people you get
notifications from even if you don't
follow them other independent voices
that question that try to have a debate
here that try to counter the narrative
that try to enter the conversation from
a point of view that's not from the
script well they get hit with fake news
accusations so this is the world that
we're living in more and more and their
their message is becoming more and more
radical i mean telling people i mean if
you're at a point where you're a media
institution and your main headline is
don't critically date
like that's when you know you're not a
part of the good guys that's when you
know you're not doing journalism that's
when you know you're not a reporter
you're a repeater for the special
billionaire globalist class that that
directly calls the shots that pays the
bills that influences our politics more
than we could even imagine but let's
let's also um you know wrap this segment
up on a high note
if if if
the fact that we're here having this
conversation and highlighting it is
proof that victory is not only possible
but our mere existence and the success
of this show and you know the work you
do with human events and luke your
channel
it's proof that victory has been
happening these are these are battles we
win every day with all the work that
we're doing i mean for everybody
watching as well supporting the work and
i mean you think about like vaccine
mandates right six months ago they were
saying oh of course we're not going to
mandate vaccines right they were just
relying on persuasion and then six
months later they're mandating them
that's that's if properly viewed that's
a loss right that's at a concession of
defeat like you were not able to
persuade people and with your methods of
persuasion and so you resorted to
government force and and like in so many
other ways right the mainstream media
corporate media has gone from we're not
worried about these competitors we are
not you know we are better at our jobs
we are more accurate people are
ultimately like some small fringe number
of people are going to rely on crazies
but like most people will rely on us and
they've also given that up they're like
oh actually
we've lost that battle too so now we
need to like
lean on the social media platforms and
get them to shut up our competition yep
yep and when we see them try and use
extreme force against parents
i gotta say it a lot of this we may look
i'll i'll say this i may fear that you
know who knows how long until they try
and you know take out our channel or
whatever you know delete it but i i will
say there's a lot of indicators that
they are they're struggling and they're
panicking and i mean establishment
forces that's this major corporations
that's republicans it's democrats they
they are they are struggling
to maintain some kind of control when
you're going after satire when you're
going after a comedy when you're going
after memes i mean that's acts of
desperation i mean this is what happened
in soviet level communist countries this
is what happened to you know my family
in poland they made sure that musicians
comedy performers uh poets those are the
first people that the soviet union went
after because they influenced culture
they influenced the general public in a
way that motivated them through art and
if i'm ever proud of anything i'm
definitely proud of my t-shirt store i'm
definitely proud of my ideas i'm proud
of my email list that's very hard to
take away because i have a physical copy
of it i'm very proud of my members area
because this is something that i've been
creating and now that they're going
after art it's truly the last kind of
sign of total
you know i don't want to be hyperbolic i
don't want to be too sensational but but
we're reaching the point of absurdity
we're reaching the point that i believe
is sort of dangerous because they're
literally trying to hit anything that
even goes against their uh cult that
even goes against their larger ideology
that goes against any kind of prevailing
uh ideas that they want to throw at you
so so this is absurd i think it's
definitely going to get worse this is
the symbols of a very insecure dangerous
empire that uh because of that
insecurity is
there there's the danger and uh that's
something to really look out for when
you say you think it'll only get worse
what exactly do you think well when you
have such insecurity when you have such
fear by the state that they literally
have to hit
uh satire comedy art and and run attack
pieces on anyone who goes against them
look what's happening kyrie irving he's
being attacked viciously he just came
out with a statement today saying it's
it's not about money it's about freedom
um and
and he's he's making a very important
stand here but everyone in the uh
establishment every sports commentator
is regurgitating the same lines against
them the same talking points they should
shut up and dribble right pretty much
yeah yeah pretty much that's the points
that they're making a whole bunch of
white people telling a black man to shut
up and dribble yeah yeah well i think
it's funny right was it who said that
first laura ingraham laura is one who
talked about it yeah i talked about
lebron right yeah
i think the difference is and we
mentioned this the other day is that
lebron was opining on politics that had
nothing to do with his game whereas
kyrie irving is saying like they're not
letting me play unless i submit to this
and i'm not going to do it yeah so
you're very different it seems like the
republicans have the opportunity to be
like the ultimate workers rights party i
i do want to say to stu a stupid comment
from from uh ingram yeah like yeah oh
yeah no like look you know i kind of i
feel like the last you know five years
there have been moments where you're
like okay that was kind of dumb right
like you and you look back at sort of
2010 era gop behavior and you're like
not not the greatest like that's kind of
tacky especially when they you know sort
of demean workers and law and like
corporate people you know um when when i
was talking talking to charlie kirk
about a lot of these issues he says he
said you know the conservatives weren't
ready for these things talking about
like populist ideas in the working class
not not the working class specifically
but there's a lot of things where he was
like we didn't realize this like the
corporations and stuff like that
and i'm just thinking like
i uh jack murphy mentioned that when the
republican party said okay to gay
marriage that allowed him to be like
okay i can i can embrace this party
right now i actually feel like what's
happening is the republican party has
shifted to the left thanks to donald
trump a lot of independent voters were
like he's the guy i'm gonna vote for
because his politics align closer with
mine populism fighting back against the
establishment less so with with
traditional conservative conservatism or
anything like that so now i i see
you know in this battle there's a more
moderate right concerned about what's
going on i think that builds a bigger
coalition and more optimism i suppose i
think so too and i mean there's there's
some democrats who are winning the alarm
bell i mean something i guess i should
have brought up for discussion is
there's this op-ed
or about this guy david shore who was on
obama's polling team and he's like a
socialist but he's one of these people
who's like hardcore poll analyst reader
and he's like ringing the alarm bells at
democrats because he's like hey guys
donald trump is really good for the
republican party as a general matter
because he reoriented their policy
positions and their their base to give
them huge structural advantages in the
senate and the electoral college and
like basically he's like we need to
radically restruct you know we need to
add states we need to do all these crazy
things in order to win um but like when
democrats are saying that the point is
like yeah republicans are you know i'm
this is why i'm not blackfield at all
like
you know if if we can get past social
media censorship and some of the other
shenanigans republicans have a much more
popular policy platform than they did 10
years ago but you know what's really
funny
if you look at the polling data the
democratic party mostly likes the
democratic party the republican voter
mostly dislikes the republican party
that's amazing it's sort of it is funny
that way it's like they're just you know
maybe eventually these congressmen will
will finally kind of rotate out we we
there is a record number of people
running is my understanding for in the
republican uh
right in the races for the republican
primaries and for congress so i'm just
saying too many republicans running is
actually bad news for republicans
but too many republicans running in the
primaries is really good news yeah
that's what needs to happen yeah and i
mean also without you know any sort of
suicide pact type stuff like i mean
again i'm going back to like lynn wood
being like don't vote for the georgia
senate candidates you see you see that
lie they put they're like donald trump
told people not to vote
no that was lynn
it's insane the story just came out
daily visa reporting that trump said
that if they don't something if they
don't like sort through the fraud then
republicans won't be voting in 2022 or
2024.
he didn't say not to vote he was
expressing his opinion that people
wouldn't have trust in the elections and
wouldn't come out
yeah i don't i don't know i i know i'll
again be i really am kind of annoyed by
comments like that because trump was
president he was he was in power to he
had the ability to do some stuff now
he's not right yeah like you know if you
want to blame anybody for like not
getting the stuff done that needed to be
done before the election blame yourself
like you were you that was your job not
to be too nihilistic but i don't think
we could vote our way out of this mess
personally myself that's just my opinion
it might be too
uh blackpill for some people but i do
think it's going to be art it's going to
be culture it's going to be memes it's
going to be ideas it's going to be
individuals standing up for their
personal individual liberties and being
personally responsible for themselves
moving away
from from such a draconian totalitarian
system and deciding that they're going
to be taking care of themselves by being
happy healthy uh and productive as much
as they can and i think the reason that
the state
thrives off of so many
people who don't think people who are
unhealthy
it's motivated in a way where you not
being
fulfilled you being weak makes the state
stronger so i think if anything's going
to happen if there's ever going to be a
change it's citizenry deciding to take
care of themselves take personal
responsibility be happy healthy and
prosperous and that will eventually
reverberate and reciprocate into people
moving away from the state and moving
towards their own kind of individual
liberty yeah you pointed out
if we can overcome the tech censorship
then yeah yeah i think that's a big one
we we're going to go to super chats but
i want to say one thing
just that i find funny uh you know back
in the day you know luke and i are
hanging out in 2011 2012 and we had this
joke that you know in 20 years or
whatever i'd be the suit wearing ceo of
a major conglomerate media company and
luke would be this still independently
run operation and he'd see me coming out
of a meeting and he'd be like tim why
did you then question me and then i'd be
like ah it's luke get out of here and
like
it's a funny joke but i'm just i'm just
thinking about how long it's been and
how much work we've put in and where we
are now you know luke's been doing this
for a lot longer than i have we were
hanging out back in 20 2011 and now here
we are you know doing doing more work
challenging these systems fighting for
freedom and and and i feel honestly if
you look at this new studio
i mean we've been winning in a lot of
ways it's gotten worse it's gotten
darker but i do believe a lot of it is
because panic and fear the establishment
has been losing control donald trump was
a huge sign they were losing control
they freaked out and boy did they slam
an iron fist and that's only going to
destabilize the system for them more as
we grow as we expand and we do more work
especially thanks to all of you who are
super chatting everybody commenting
everybody liking everybody who watch who
reads human events who watches we are
change who watches tim cast you guys all
of us together
let's read some super chats and get down
to if you haven't already smash that
like button
maud dibs says tim have you listened to
data and picard by pogo if if not you
should also here's a dune quote to
accept a little death is worse than
death itself johnny
interesting great song by pogo
is it we should have him all right
let's see andrew kempker says give ian
his own show or podcast through tim cass
to elaborate on his ideas
i would love a cooking show i think that
cooking segment on the vlog was
brilliant i would love to see more
personally i did a a little gem segment
earlier on the vlog tim the tim what is
it the cass castle vlog and uh
that was really good i agree i would
like to do a show maybe with andreas
like an after show late night like we'll
call it like the late late late late
show dude you and andre four o'clock in
the morning that would be like the
ultimate like i need to be high
uh all right what do we got here um
let's see
carl andrews says luke i will follow you
on insta and anywhere for that matter
from the poop-covered sidewalks of
california to the thousand-yard ranges
of fredamastan amen thank you we we went
to for damastan today we rode the bikes
around there's an old cemetery on it
from the 1700s
apparently like people pull up and try
and go like they want to go and they're
like hey can i go to the cemetery
because on this private property and i
don't think we'd have a thousand yard
range
but i think we'll have a good range a
good one um it's a big property it's
like a little there's a little hill you
know it's not too crazy but it'll be a
lot of fun
i love cemeteries man i grew up with a
cemetery right outside my backyard like
there's a little fence oh wow the big
cemetery i grew up pretty close to
resurrection cemetery where the famous
story of resurrection mary takes place
you guys should read that ghost story
maybe maybe for our tales from the
inverted world we can have shane
investigate some of these chicago ghost
stories i was talking about i was like
dude chicago's got so much like
bachelor's grove man there's
that's a story that needs to be written
about more like people have written
about it but as time goes on more weird
stuff emerges
all right seven om cruz says tim you
bought the wrong motorcycle you are
never gonna experience the joy of a long
distance ride on that rocket jokes aside
congratulations on your new ride stay
safe and your wheel stay safe and your
wheels on the road so i got the zero srs
it's an electric motorcycle because we
got those onyx bikes and people
commented those are not the tesla of the
the tesla's motorcycles zero is and then
we looked into it and the srs is like oh
man i i gotta say um
amazing motorcycle
zero to sixty like in a couple seconds i
was i went from 65 to like zero in a
couple seconds which is kind of scary
because i just stopped for a hard turn
it is silent
it is
quiet
just so quiet i'm worried i'll get hit
you know i i i mean i don't mean to be
like
if you're worried about you should be
worried about getting hit so my mom was
a lawyer and she did insurance defense
right so that means like somebody you
know is usually like various types of
injuries and then she represents the
insurance company if it goes to
litigation and through her experience
and then she said to me will there's two
things i never want you to do one of
them is go on a carnival ride right and
the second is to ride a motorcycle
like and that's just you know that's her
thing like she was like if you don't do
those two things you'll probably be okay
but the carnival rides the temporary you
know she's like amusement parks fine
it's fixed it's very strong temporary
carnival rides never i've never ever
i think i think people uh
you know the way i approach the riding
the motorcycle is just i do very
different things right so when i'm
getting off the highway i do a right
turn three times instead of taking a
left turn and you know it might sound
paranoid or whatever but i there's a
story right now about this like uh
amateur skateboarder like not not like
somebody was actually paid to do it
they're called am and uh he was stone
cold sober riding his bike and someone
just hit him because people don't see
you so i my view of it is look it's not
a long-distance bike it's range about
100 miles i treat it like
you know there's a very very high risk
factor so you know you got to go with
traffic but when i'm exiting we actually
have a way we can come to the property
where you don't turn left off of the
highway when it runs down you turn right
and then loop around and then go down so
those right turns are faster easier
safer things like that i'm not planning
on taking this bike on you know using it
for everything short short rides and
stuff but i was reading i think it's
like one in four people get an accident
yeah my dad was a fireman for 25 years
also named tim and uh the worst injury
he got was before he was a fireman on a
motorcycle he hit something on the road
and flew over the front of the bike and
then the bike ran him over and broke his
leg and he has a big iron rod metal rod
in his leg still to this yeah i mean a
good friend of ours i don't know if you
know alec baker but he's like sort of in
conservative world uh he worked for i
think
cassie dillon for a while or something
like that but anyway he got a motorcycle
three weeks later massive injury broke
his leg in like three places he was a
year of rehab so wow what happened uh
i think he just got i don't know if it
was rear-ended but he got hit by a jeep
yep and that's the other thing too it's
like uh
yeah i'm just not i'm not gonna be
taking a bike into like i'm not going to
be using it for for regular travel yeah
you know we're going to we're going to
we're going to use it for more country
stuff less yeah open roads well it might
be my dad for fun it was he was him
alone with the bike and he something
knocked him over the front of the thing
i almost hit a deer it was running at an
angle towards me and then i was like
okay we're going to collide i hit the
brakes and it just zoomed right in front
of me man that's crazy all right we got
some super chats here let's see jirene
johnny says i will be losing a
six-figure job in the coming weeks i've
done dod cyber security for almost 20
years company is looking at a 30 to 40
loss of manpower so we get regular
emails reminding us to comply i shall
not comply thank you for doing what you
do thank you i saw a post i don't know
if it's true and they were like a
company announced vaccine mandates and
then they mentioned it was an airport i
don't know if you saw this post they
were like the sea terminal at some
airport the restaurant owner mandated
everybody get vaccine mandates and then
the next day
half the staff didn't show up so all the
restaurants were closed and he sent an
email saying the policies rescinded
everyone come to work
yeah i mean i i have enormous respect
for people who who do not comply with
the mandates and make meaningful and
make serious sacrifices like that like i
don't think i don't think everybody's in
a position to do that and i don't i
don't begrudge people who don't right
like some people need the money some
people like for whatever reason like
they need the money they can't they just
can't be unemployed and
treat those people as having been
coerced right like they've been
meaningfully coerced into doing it but
people who don't i mean kyrie i think i
think kyrie irving is doing is one of
the most brave things i've ever seen
dudes giving up 200 million dollars 200
because he's not just giving up his
current your salary he's giving up well
i mean he's not he's giving up his
chance as an extension with the team he
currently work which is because and the
way the nba pay structure works i mean i
don't know if it'll be ultimately a full
200 million dollar loss but it'll be
substantial because if you switch teams
the the amount you can sign for is
dramatically and the years are reduced
too and sponsorship deals and
advertisements all of that i mean it's
it's a very i mean very very brave thing
to be doing and a very like he has a ton
of skin in the game and it's just you
know you compare this to things like you
know widespread blm protests where it's
like they're basically just doing what
the establishment wanted everybody went
along with it no meaningful risk if
anything you you're the risk is
not going along with it um and you
compare that to this where he's just
completely out on an island with
everyone from the corporations the
administration the mainstream media
everyone just giving it to him all right
this one's a spicy one sonny james says
this whole
this this is the whole problem with the
cia and the fbi they're lazy they want
unemployment and postmates it's easy to
chase down people who aren't running
it's not even cool to belong to the cia
or fbi anymore they can't even pull off
a good psyop equivalent to working at bk
at least you get free cheeseburgers when
you work at burger king right i think
they're pretty good at psyopses so
especially if you i don't i can't even
mention
all right let's have you on the after
lately
here's a super chat i'm going to read
mostly because i won't nick s says and
i'm going to read it verbatim
is tim you're either dumb or naive if
the doj will do nothing in support of
the january 6 writers but you won't read
this because it's critical of why
what well what
what
i read i read comments on a credit card
i think his legal analysis is better
than his grammar but it's a close war
what is he saying i don't actually know
what that means i don't know what he's
saying
right i think he's saying that
i'm dumb
if the doj will do nothing in support of
the january 6 writers so that is to say
if the doj supports the rioters i'm
smart well hey read that again really
quick i think i got it is it maybe like
he's trying to say that
the doj won't will throw the book at the
rioters and you're dumb and naive if you
think they won't i don't know maybe but
then but then we have the experience of
like all these misdemeanors here we go i
love this one nick s here he comes again
you weren't arrested tim it's called
being detained
wrong
so what's the difference tell him he's
wrong uh i nick you're you're wrong
when a police officer stops you and says
you are under arrest you are not being
detained you have been arrested it's a
it's like a more extreme form of
detention well i mean so detained is
like there's something called
like a terry stop
um right like so basically if the
officer has a reasonable suspicion that
criminal activity is afoot they can stop
you and and frisk you for example and
and they can ask you questions in other
circumstances you are being detained you
are not free to leave but there's like a
there's a natural like time limit on
that i think it's like most
jurisdictions i think it's 45 minutes
something like that it could be i think
in illinois it might be 15. so when
you're detained they say you ask am i
being detained no you're then you say
okay then i'm leaving when you're
arrested there is no time limit and
you're not free to leave right however
being arrested doesn't mean you're going
to be charged or processed people don't
know this because they get their
information from tv shows
so when i was stopped by the cops and
told three times by the supervisor you
have been placed under arrest you are
not free to leave sit down and wait and
unless right and also you are not free
to leave when you're being detained
either it's just that there's that time
limit on it and i think the standard is
like it's a reasonable suspicion when
you're being detained right like the cop
just can't just stop and frisk you for
no good reason at all right like you
have to have like some suspicion
but to arrest you right which means that
they can bring you to jail book you etc
then you have probable cause they need
to have probable cause that you you
committed a crime so there was a group
of people that were surrounded by cops
this was a large black block antifa type
group that had been starting fires and
smashing windows and everybody in that
group got
surrounded by all the police and they
came out and said you have all been
placed under arrest you are not free to
go and we are now going to start loading
people up into the vans one at a time
people were held there for like eight
hours or something however for me after
the supervisor told me three times to my
face outside of the formal announcement
he said sir you've been arrested just
wait and i said i'm just letting you
know i'm a journalist he's like okay
eventually a local news outlet
boss called the department said why are
you arresting our journalists get him
out of there when he came to paul out
there's this little asian woman i was
standing next to her and i held up my
card and he went okay and he pulled me
out and he goes you got a press card and
i was like it's right here and i gave to
him and he goes all right you can leave
so when you're told several times you
are not being detained you are being
arrested and you can't leave and you sit
there for over an hour that is not a
detainment do they need to tell you what
you're being arrested for even if they
don't book you nope nope
people people think like oh i love it
someone said did they read you your
rights
can you please can you please help us
with this one you're you are not
guaranteed to read your rights and most
of the time you are not this is a this
is a tv thing right like because it's
like law and order right like they place
the person under the arrest walk them
off the handcuffs and read them as
miranda writes generally speaking people
only read their miranda rights when
they're subject to a custodial
interrogation because the entire point
of miranda is so you can use the
testimony in court but if you're not
interrogating someone you don't need to
mirandize them if the police watch you
throw a brick or see a group of people
with you in it throw a brick and they
decide they're taking they're gonna
there's gonna be criminal charges
against this group they don't need to
investigate any further their testimony
is i watched him do it
my fellow officer is a witness who
watched him do it they're not gonna read
you your rights yeah and also generally
the way it works is before you know
you've seen the you know this is the
thing you know there's the custodial
interrogation room where the police
officers come in and ask questions of
them before that starts you are handed a
piece of paper and that's how you are
given your rights generally is that you
you know on the piece of paper
and you sign
you know that you've you've been made
aware of your miranda rights and then
they can come in and start questioning
you
like yeah but on tv they want to say it
out loud right right
there's there's a famous viral video
from occupy where a woman's being
arrested and she's going i have not been
read my rights and it's like so you're
aware of them
[Laughter]
you're not being investigated for
anything they're charging you with like
obstructing a roadway they don't need to
interrogate you to figure out you did it
yeah
you know people get their get their news
from tv shows and movies they're legal
analysis silencers
right yeah their legal analysis from
watching law order
all right let's see
blave kaiser says but bill maher says
getting involved in local elections and
primaries are a slow coup he said trump
is performing a slow coup by getting
involved
participating in democracy is a coup
oh man bill maher is so close but he
won't he won't stop he wants up over
that line oh maybe he will psilocybin i
don't know what's it gonna be bill
i don't know man
all right let's see punk rock fox says
tim i am freaking out i was able to get
a ticket to your event but the site
would only allow me to grab one ticket i
wanted two and i can't leave my
girlfriend behind we are both huge fans
you know
are they uh are they plus one or not
they're the so the tickets are not plus
one the issue is that you can bring a
friend if you're a member you can get it
you can sign up to get a ticket for
another person
if they're not members they won't be let
in unless they're with you so you can
get a ticket for a plus one we we went
over a lot of ways to try and figure out
the best way to go about doing this so
the idea is if you're a 25 member or
more then you would get advanced notice
and so right now the post is only
available to people who are members at
25 or more the 10 members didn't have
access to it because we wanted to be
like for those that are really diehard
fans we want to make sure you can come
and uh it's sold out instantly
so the idea was everybody needs a plus
one people can't come by themselves so
you could click rsvp get a ticket and
then have your friend take another wife
whatever also get a ticket and then they
could come with you but they could only
get in if they were with someone because
we're gonna check at the door which
meant basically about a hundred tickets
because we were initially planning on
only doing like 30 and we're like we'll
do a real venue and it's just
i think the harsh realities of life is
there's no way for us to do an event
that would be
like that would work in this way if we
had a thousand tickets or two thousand
tickets or three thousand because you
get to that point it's no longer a
hangout meet and greet it's just us on
stage waving to you and then leaving
the daily wire did uh recently the
videos on check them out um where they
have like a thousand person event those
are cool too so what they did
what they did was that with that was
they had 300 people who got tickets to
do like a meet and greet thing with them
out of those 2 000 yeah so they had a
big event but they had a very much
smaller event where they actually were
like shaking hands and like making
people exhausted by having these small
conversations i will just make sure i
stress this point right now
if someone shows up and doesn't have a
ticket they can't get in because we are
just going to a small private venue and
we don't have the capacity so if you
have a ticket you can come
and my apologies if we could do it could
have done a better job we will learn
from this and we'll do something better
but let me just stress as well with
fradamstan we are planning to never have
this problem again because we're going
to just have a big open field and we're
going to have an event perhaps the free
dome
the freedom giant even like old
coachella type thing
yeah it's going to be it's it's freedom
free freedom stand you know freedom
i don't know land you have freedom
freedom stands freedom party or
something and then we can actually
accommodate like couple hundred more
people
and then still you know it is difficult
to hang out and meet people and play
pool and watch comedy when you have this
massive massive show i don't want to do
a you know a stadium thing i don't want
to do like a big venue you know because
then it's basically just doing a show
and waving to people and they get to
look at you but then you don't get to
actually hang out and meet people
but that means also smaller events but
if we we're planning on doing them once
a month so you know we'll we'll figure
something out one of the one of the one
of the ideas was that you can't go to
two two events consecutively yeah i was
thinking of that too that crossed my
mind yeah if if like you go to the
october event then in november you know
we're like sorry you know you can't you
come and you know but we gotta figure it
out you know so uh 200 tickets were
already dished out you need to take it
to get in we're going to be checking
memberships at the door
if you uh uh if you got a ticket for
your friend who's not a member they can
come in with you
we'll figure it out we're not an events
company so we should definitely get an
events plan we we should and we should
take the show on the road and hit every
major capital and do thousand-seat live
show events
just my personal bias amanda dilts says
tim fix the sword you talk about gun
edict sword edict is point edge
point down edge down i see in case
someone puts their hand like that you
don't want them to get cut on the blade
i guess the concern was that we didn't
want to actually rest the blade against
anything
but we'll flip it over yeah
although they're not i guess it's
technically a real sword like we have
the zelda you know you know what i want
to do we should do this we should take
the master sword and like
actually make it a sword
that thing yeah the the the the master
sword from zelda is actually just a big
piece of metal it's not actually a sword
but you know we'll do we'll do that
all right let's read some super chats
okay
downey jr says hi tim please have a look
at freespeech freespeechunion.org they
provide legal support in the uk for
cancel culture victims douglas murray is
a director it's similar to what you
suggested to james o'keefe search nick
buckley's story interesting yeah that
that sounds cool freespeech union.org i
have the big fat blade here
this would be this would make a a good
real sword it is not real it is not
sharp and it has a plastic hilt that
will shatter in two seconds if you
actually tried to use that thing yeah
it's higher pitch than that
yeah yeah that's how he does it
okay let's see
roberto lara says tim memes were
basically the main focus in the game
metal gear rising revengeance check it
out tim or ian also clock clock that's
right roberto is the name of our rooster
and roberto roberto jr is his son i
looked out the window about 8 30 this
morning and i saw tim walking like this
with two chickens on his arms just
walking
i did have two chickens i thought it was
hilarious
we call them the poo babies because
three babies hatched and they just you
know because chickens just crap
everywhere
they'll like walk over their food dish
eat turn around and just dump right into
their food
so you know that's what they do gross
wow yeah the joke is that they're smart
enough not to drink their water after
they crap in it but they're not smart
enough not to crap in their own water
that's chickens
so yeah they're they're they're big
enough now
um i think they're i think they're the
pole hen stage but no no they're not
they're not they're they're still
bullets and and but uh roberto jr is
getting big he he he's roberto sonny's
gonna be a rooster and he went
like he tried he's trying he's bless his
heart
i think he's getting trained by roberto
how to scream you know interestingly i
was worried that the older chickens
would abuse them
and they did nip at them like at their
faces but for the most part they're
chill they're all they're all super
chill yeah the original older chickens
the parents and everything just like
look at them and like get all confused
and look at me and then just walk away
the most they do is they like you know
jump at them and then just go back about
their business to like shoo them away
but uh yeah yeah the chicken babies are
getting pretty big so i was trying to
move them you know away from really
funny to look out the window and see tim
walker with chickens on his arms two of
them one and it looked really balanced
like he was like the lady of the blind
lady of justice
scale
royal wolf says ian fingers cows
confirmed
i never have technically but alex jones
yeah technically never just in my mind
uh yeah alex confirmed that it does feel
good
to put your finger in a cow's mouth you
just don't want to upset the cow while
you're doing it and you want to make
sure it's a kind of i mean i would don't
do it i'm not saying to do it i'm just
saying i genuinely would not have
guessed that alex jones would have uh
that level of expertise
interesting manifest manifested destiny
says i think sanjay was a compromise
between rogan and cnn to avoid
litigation sanjay laid down for cnn joe
got to humiliate him i think joe figured
out when too much money is too much
money uh yeah i wonder if joe reached
out and like a legal letter and they
were like what can we do and then he and
then maybe maybe he'd rather he was like
get on the show explain it but no i just
think sanjay just spoke no maybe well
maybe sanjay didn't know
to joe's audience sanjay gupta saying
you are right
i mean that kind of resolves a lot of
the defamation claim right yeah but then
why would they let their own people
double down and claim that they weren't
right like i've seen it you know it
doesn't make sense that
but lemon and aaron burnett have sanjay
on to make him like recant
yeah gotta sue him
manuel delgado says tim and will you
complain and rag on the republicans fail
to acknowledge the majority are boomers
and corporate shills we need young blood
running this country william you sound
more like a rhino
oh savage shots fired i know
[Laughter]
like i think republicans should win and
and it's good that we're trumpist except
that i don't think i think i think
rhino's a compliment i mean rand paul is
a rhino you know why yeah because he's
the outlier the republican party is the
party of mcconnell and lindsey graham
rand paul's like the one guy who's
actively like yeah
like i don't know how you i mean if you
think that josh holly and ron desantis
and and ted cruz and cotton like my
peter thiel my guys
are the rhinos then like
i don't know what republican party
you're a part of but it's not the one i
understand that exists and it's and it's
it's a very weird one it's like it's
like the people who said like basically
i wonder if the critique is that i'm not
neocon enough or something i don't know
i don't know
brandon d says joe rogan engaged sanjay
in verbal jiu-jitsu and got the
submission of course he's joe
all right
james garlic says tim i watch all of
your content every day unfortunately i
always have to go to your channel to
watch your two daily tim cast as it's
shadow band for me to keep up for me
keep up the good work all of you
you know
that's uh that's that's that's what
youtube does yeah you can go to his
channel and go through a bunch of videos
like open up like 30 or 40 of those
videos and like them all and like like a
bunch of videos from a channel
we don't want to call for spamming oh
okay but that that seems to tell the
algorithm i want to see more of this no
that's why
if somebody watches a video they can
press like otherwise you can find the
channels youtube.com
okay yeah they need to watch the video
and then decide if they like it right
yeah if you if you like it you like it
so be sure to like the videos you watch
that you like exactly because that's
what i've been doing with irl and it
pops up in my feed yeah there you go
poofy says yo do that ethan klein
impression again i don't remember how i
did it you don't even have to you don't
have to read bro yeah you don't even
have to read bro you got to think about
it listen yeah you never think about it
yeah i'm an independent voice that's
right yeah that's me
is he really doing that show with hassan
are they really doing that that was a
joke i think it was a joke yeah oh yeah
yeah because he's
like
i i
even klein is is you know well well
entitled to do us you know commentary on
pop culture and stuff but like
man telling telling people not to be to
purposefully be irresponsible and not
actually like consult doctors was just
one of the most redundant i thought the
whole crowder stump was ridiculous
the one where he like you know agreed to
a debate and then he like brought on
somebody else to do the debate that he
had agreed to
like
dudes dude's kind of weak i don't know i
don't know i don't watch his content but
every time i hear about something he
says or does it's like embarrassing and
clownish
chris crow says tim your game room is
lacking a pinball machine yeah pinball
machines cost like seven grand yeah i
was talking about the other days
yeah and they're really noisy but that
was the first thing i wanted yeah i was
like i want to get a bit more machine
and then look at the price and i was
like i don't want to get a pinball
machine anymore uh but the arcade
machine with like 30 000 games on it was
way cheaper oh i played some mario
brothers today i'm talking the og mario
brothers that's the high score contest i
think i can beat that because i got
really far the first time i played on
one life
all right
okay
nick in the focus as tim make an app
with audio and or video my pocket keeps
clicking off your videos while i'm
working
if you use the brave browser apparently
this allows you to sleep your phone and
have the audio keep playing
because brave is awesome yeah we was
brave actually you can see you can see
the little brave symbol bravely
incredible
all right let's see what we got
colin p says sanjay's book publisher
sent him to rogan not cnn hmm
interesting that's probably i could see
that for sure right the book publisher
being like you need to build your own
platform you need a chance to market
this to a big audience i mean it's one
thing to just get a random small cnn hit
it's another thing to be able to go on
rogan which has a huge audience and then
have their attention for hours
you know yeah vince r says why hasn't
anyone asked to spin that ufo spin it
i'm spinning it oh oh oh this one is
going to spin that ufo
and if you if you're a real adam krigler
fan you know this isn't adam's ufo his
is silver mine is black that's still my
that's the technically still adam's ufo
is still technically tim's before you're
a real adam krugman fan you would know
that that was well so what happened one
day is uh he was doing his show and my
phone's bluetooth was on while i was
listening to some music video or
something and when i walked past the
hallway it automatically automatically
connected to the ufo and then started
playing music because it's a bluetooth
speaker that's amazing and hilarious
yeah and then
yeah it was funny i know you're out
there
someone's con i've convinced a 23-year
libertarian not to vote desantis i saw
that one oh nice yeah daniel williams
says okay i don't like will anymore and
you have convinced a 23-year libertarian
not to vote to santa's wife uh well i
mean i'm not a libertarian so my
arguments are not libertarian so it's
unsurprising that i am not persuasive to
libertarians libertarians all right
kj9109 says you talked about artists
being shut down this is part of why nfts
are blowing up the art is immutable on
the blockchain with a vibrant
counterculture forming curio cards
crypto punks and rare pepes were early
trailblazers creating uh check out what
artists are doing we are going to be
launching a bunch of nfts
so we're going to be doing you know you
know i think one of the best things that
anyone can do for a special show like
this is sell and give away as much of
our stuff as possible so like
ian's obsidian i love these things we
could we could do a giveaway you know
where we like we'll do like half to
charity and half to the company or
whatever to support our journalists or
we can be like for open network
foundation
so we could say something like you know
uh we have uh yeah like ian's obsidian
rock could be put up and like if you
want to get this it's ian's rocks he has
everyone handsome to everybody and then
that money can go to fund the openness
these are great by the way this is a
wonderful like almost fidget spinner
type yeah right right and then we're
gonna do nfts the same thing so there
can be like an nft version
and then someone could buy it and then
we use that money to fund the nonprofits
the charities and the fact checking
something i want to do with the
nonprofit charity that we just started
is not only will be paying the
developers that are building out the
metaverse but i think we can use charity
funds to host a node to actually host
bandwidth and that can be like part of
the charity function yep server space
actually you know making it work so
we're going to do nfts we're going to do
event auctions we're going to do a whole
bunch of stuff and you know the the most
important thing i think for people is
that you know having a having a part of
the show having a part of the art having
something that like allows you to be a
part of it and have something unique no
one else can have like if if we sold
this like only you would have it
only the one person who got it would
actually have it and that would be
unique along with the nfts with that
being said my friends make sure you
smash that like button it's great
greatly appreciated and you uh you
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends
you can follow us uh everywhere at tim
cast irl we were banned on tick tock
we might get reinstated who knows i have
no idea but maybe and you can follow me
personally at tim cast so make sure you
follow me on all these wonderful places
you can follow me on instagram too and
uh will you want to show anything up
sure yeah um
follow me on twitter at will chamberlain
i also do periscopes i was doing a daily
show i'm probably going to go back to it
but we we had to do a pause for
various internal business reasons also
at human events um that's
humanevents.com
and i will never stop crack posting top
quality memes on instagram at luke we
are change but if they do take me down
sign up on my email list which is
available on we are change.org and if
you're asking about the shirt you could
only get it on
lukeuncensored.com it's only for members
there's no profit and it's our uniform
so uh thanks guys for supporting me and
having me here it's always fun to be
able to say whatever i want what i want
and to be able to express myself here so
thanks so much i would only ask lydia
that you cue up the wide shot i want you
guys at home to uh wherever you are
listening to see if you can spot that
gorilla with the obsidian between his
legs when this shot comes up let me see
if i can do that i'm ian crossland only
give him a few seconds of it though see
if they can spot it in time okay there
we go we need to do a fake credits so
that we can do the wide shot and then
and we'll play like just put orwell in
there put 1984 the whole book but make
it go really fast
there you go that'd be great i love that
you guys i am also having oh here see i
have to switch to camera still and i
always forget to do it i'm getting good
at it
i'm also have a similar i'm having a
similar fight with instagram right now
they're taking down my old memes i've
never posted anything unkind nothing
rude nothing bullying in there
threatening to take my whole account
down uh over stuff that i posted well
over a year ago so if you guys would
like to follow me on instagram i'm at
real sour patch lids over there and on
twitter i'm sour patch leads thanks guys
we will see you all over at timcast.com
for that special members only segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you